So today we're going to be speaking with
Brett Cooper she's one of the most
prominent gen Z political commentators
who's quickly grown an audience of more
than two and a half million through her
outspoken opposition to the woke agenda
with the daily wire I guess you might
also know her as the female Ben Shapiro
what surprised me most about this
episode was just how shocking her story
was and how that led to her beliefs
today I was emancipated at 15 and I
moved to California to pursue acting
about 10 years ago I was acting in
Atlanta first lived in New York for a
bit doing theater then went out to LA
for film and TV and so I was working
there professionally for about 10 years
you're going to want to make sure to
subscribe because next week we're also
posting our discussions with Hassan
[__] who's on the complete opposite end
of the political spectrum and you don't
want to miss out on that so subscribe
and now with that said a quick message
from our video sponsor first by the way
man now that we're off camera I wanted
to run by you my next business idea it's
basically like Drop Shipping but for
endangered animal species cameras are
still on nobody steal my idea anyways
man I'm still trying to figure out how
to get it funded and getting a bank loan
has been an absolute nightmare well I
mean if simple and hassle free funding
is what you're looking for then our
sponsor fund and grow is able to help
and they're down below in the
description wait Graham down below where
the description Jack not not under the
table what about my endangered animals
it's on you
look fund and grow understands how
difficult it could be for small
businesses to get a loan bank loans are
notoriously restrictive and full of red
tape but unlike a bank loan funded grow
offers a 12-month membership where you
could secure up to 250 000 of credit at
zero percent interest without giving up
any equity in your company fund and grow
already has over 4 000 4.9 star reviews
and I think that's because people are
seeing genuine results from such fast
and simple funding and as a special
offer for our listeners fun and grow has
prepared a business funding master class
with five simple steps of how to get 250
000 in business credit plus as an
exclusive bonus you'll receive a 500
discount on their services so don't wait
to fund and grow your business visit
fund and grow today using the link Down
Below in the description and also guys
make sure to check out what's called
iced coffee hour dot Club because
the.com was taken we're actually doing
this kind of right now we're filming an
episode just with Jack and I about uh
you know business and behind the scenes
and all that so if you guys are
interested check out iced coffeeour.club
or the link is down below in the
description go check it out and now
let's get into the podcast welcome back
to the iced coffee hour I'm Brett Cooper
we are here in Nashville at our Studios
I just made some iced coffee in my
office for Jack and Graham how do you
think it is I think it's fantastic it's
growing on me the first few sips were I
would say eight out of ten okay 9.5 out
of 10. awesome I mean I took a risk by
putting the Chick-fil-A ice in there
yeah I knew it was going to melt faster
it's bold I didn't put it in yours
though no I got the regular ice uh
mine's great though I put hazelnut in
this that's good 20 semised coffee
cheers guys cheers thank you so much for
doing this yes really appreciate it
excited
imagine you just start choking on it
Jack we came all the way here to
Nashville for you and you were so
gracious this entire set you guys set it
up extremely appreciative of it we just
I feel like we can't not mention what
just happened we went to go tour some
homes you and Graham were like filming
because yeah you're looking to buy a
house we can talk about that later and
while you were filming just after we
arrive at the house there was some
banging loud banging I thought Jack had
fault he he thought Jack had fallen he
thought I'd slip down the stairs and
yeah no I didn't feel about to walk up
the steps I was like oh crap I was yeah
he thought I felt but actually what
happened was a huge limb off of a tree
fell over crashed over probably totaled
two yeah three cars three cars yeah I
mean that was freaky it was like your
entire cruise cars so we have a tornado
warning all day today but the storm we
thought was going to be over obviously
um so we were gonna cancel the video
because we weren't even sure because it
was storming or like should we even go
out there and then it was so Sunny so
yeah it was wild I'm grateful that
everybody's okay though you know it
works out better for my video I get
excited for this weather though I have
to say like when it's windy like that it
was raining earlier I was so excited I
told Jack earlier like it's supposed to
uh they're supposed to be lightning and
thunder like I was looking forward to
that extreme conditions are the best I
grew up in like Ventura which is a very
temperate place and whenever I see
extreme temperatures or extreme winds
and stuff like that it just excites me
because it's so normal there yeah it's a
blessing yeah so well tell us a bit
about your story uh I first found you I
think on Twitter okay because the female
Ben Shapiro and I saw the resemblance
and I thought okay you guys are related
somehow to clear the air you guys are
not related we're not related although
you gave me the great idea that we
should do a DNA test just to see if
there's any there might be something
there yeah I mean because I didn't see
it I think it's the eyebrows but I
really don't know we should actually do
a side by side but I've seen it in some
photos
um but the mannerisms too are like very
similar I would say so yeah and I didn't
grow up watching Ben so that's one like
I don't think I adopted it because of
that sure
um I was like a hardcore like Michael
Knowles fan I love to like you know can
this before coming here but I would
listen to Ben and I knew who he was but
I wasn't somebody who literally watched
his show and so a lot of people you know
have said you know oh you know you're
right wing you probably like grew up
watching Ben like that's why you talk
I'm like literally no we just speak very
very quickly and talk with our hands a
lot apparently
um but no so yeah I am the daily wire
now I host the comment section was not
hired because of any relation to daily
wire even though many people think that
but I am originally from Chattanooga
Tennessee and then I moved to California
to pursue acting about 10 years ago I
was acting in Atlanta first lived in New
York for a bit doing theater and then
went out to LA for film and TV and so I
was working there professionally for
about 10 years how did you get into
acting so I was deathly shy as a child
and my brother's high school was doing a
production of The Wiz and which is like
an adaptation of Wizard of Oz and they
needed the siblings of some of the kids
at school to be like the munchkins at
the end of the show and like to stand
like do a couple of songs and then come
out and be like cute and tiny I think it
was five at the time no five or six
um deathly shy my mom knew some people
that were working you know on the show
my brothers were not into theater
whatsoever and she was like this is the
opportunity to get my kid like over this
because I would not talk to people and
this was like something that she was
actively working on
my mother's incredible she was a very
very intentional parent and so she knew
I was very shy so she would you know
stand outside of a gas station bring and
you know make me go inside with a five
dollar bill and buy something she would
watch me like go up with you know to the
counter with a candy bar and have to
talk to the person why are we shine do
you remember like the reason was it
nervous of strangers not really I don't
really know I just think I was
uncomfortable
um not to go you know go in a totally
different direction but one of my
brothers died when I was five years old
and so I think I mean that totally blew
up the dynamic of my family and I think
at a very young age that was something I
didn't really understand I remember at
one point like we had a bunch of people
at our house shortly after he died like
you know bringing casseroles and that
sort of thing and I was literally like
hiding in a Cupboard and I was just like
I didn't really know how to process it
my whole family was very chaotic I
didn't really know how to interact with
people at school after that it was very
very defensive and I think I just kind
of shut down
um because it you know five years old
how are you supposed to process anything
like that and I think my family was so
concerned with you know my older
brothers who were you know seemingly
more impacted by it than I was so I
would say that is the root cause of it
obviously I don't have that issue
anymore
um I credit a lot of that to acting so I
think that was why but she was very
intentional with getting me out of my
shell and making sure that you know once
she noticed that this was a pattern just
like I want to make sure that this is
addressed so she signed me up to
basically do the show and was like maybe
she'll like it I don't know never you
know did any theater herself was never a
stage mom never wanted that I thought it
would be a one and done and I fell in
love with it like I just came alive I
loved music even before that I you know
I was already doing ballet and I just
loved performing and I loved
storytelling in any capacity
um and then I just kept begging to do
more shows so I did a few other shows
with the high school just being like the
you know one of ten siblings that would
be on stage like doing a little dance
number to Community Theater
um auditioned for a few Regional
professional Productions my first
professional job was singing with the
Atlanta Symphony and Opera and I was one
of their like chorus kids and was paid
to do Opera basically at I think 70
years old eight years old started doing
like long-running Regional Productions I
did a you know production of Annie that
I think ran for four months when I was
10 years old and then got a
representation so I had an agent and
manager at the time they brought whose
idea was that because there's a big leap
between doing this was all what you were
doing and getting into that like in a
manner so I with doing professional
things I just kept asking for more and
so you know our community theater didn't
really have a ton of Productions where
they would you know have kids involved
and so I would say like where else could
I audition like what where else can I go
um and so we would you know my mom and I
would sit at the computer and I would
find okay well this one's an hour away
let's do this you'd go on the computer
and find rooms you would go together
yeah what did you like so much about it
I love the fact that I could
tell stories to somebody else something
that I've dealt with for a very long
time is that I felt like I could not
actually effectively communicate what I
was feeling I was like very very bottled
up and I you know credit a lot of that
to my family not only did my brother die
my you know parents had a very very
messy divorce just grew up in a very
very turbulent home and I think that
acting gave me the outlet that I needed
in order to express myself and I loved
telling stories I loved being able to be
somebody else for two hours so it might
have been a bit of an escape in a sense
or just like you zone out you could be
somebody else tell a story I love it um
I loved connecting with an audience too
I mean I did you know TV and film for 10
years but when I am on stage just like
nothing else like the energy of having
hundreds of people in the room and they
are along the journey with you and I
think that's the beautiful thing about
theaters whenever I hear people be like
I don't really like musical theater I
don't like theater I'm like just try it
because you're sitting in this room
together as a community going through
this like hour and a half long long
journey together and as the actor on
stage it's a much more demanding task
because you can't really take breaks
it's not like ah you know I screwed up
that line let me try it again sure it's
like you are in it for an hour and a
half the adrenaline rush is insane you
are outside of yourself basically for an
hour and a half and even as a kid I
think I needed that and I just became a
totally different person
um and it broke me out of my shell I had
so much fun yeah it was a big leap so I
started doing professional stuff and I
had this one goal I wanted to be Jane
banks in the Broadway production of Mary
Poppins which was currently on Broadway
at the time I think it was probably 10
or 11. I had seen the musical multiple
times I was like that is what I want I
want to play that role it's so fun so
then this is all people sometimes people
don't believe it but like my mother did
not want me to do this she wasn't like
actively act like going against it but
she was like I'm not going to push you
to do this like we live in Tennessee my
brothers were in college he was dealing
with a failing marriage like this was
not the time to be like getting her kid
into professional whatever I wrote a
letter to a manager who wrapped three of
the girls that had been Jane banks on
Broadway and I found him because I would
watch I would actively watch interviews
of like young women that were on
Broadway like anywhere from my age to
like 15 years old like how did they do
this how do they get to do that and I
saw this guy like for the interviews
like um and he was their agent at the
time and then he became a manager so I
found where he was currently working and
I wrote him a letter and I said you know
these are all the things that I've been
in I desperately want to be Jane Banks
and then I he still has it I think but I
did a drawing of myself in the Jane
Banks outfit on a stage and I sent it to
him
100 I'm somebody that like I will take
take any risk if I can give one piece of
advice to anybody my age it's just like
just ask if you just write a letter if
you just like the worst that somebody
can say is no but at least you tried
people are so damn terrified to just
shoot your shot it's like please just go
for it
um anyway so I sent this letter and I
got an email back and he was like will
you fly up to New York and meet with me
so I remember going to his tiny office
in Manhattan and I sang a song and I did
a monologue how old were you at the time
uh I was 10 years old so I'm gonna flew
off with me and she was like this what
are her thoughts like you're flying to
New York to meet with a guy who's
repping these people on Broadway she
means she did like you know research
about him and was like are we going into
that kind of thing but wait were you
sending this directly to him was she
like the intermediary like you're giving
it to her and she sends it to him yes
like we would go like we went to the
mailbox together and like send it off
but I was the driving force behind all
of it I bet she's thinking like oh this
is cute let's just do this exactly yeah
and to her you know parenting so I don't
think that she would have done this if
my brother had not died
um her parenting style totally changed
after my brother David's death
um and she has made most decisions since
then based on
um especially in my youth you know if
she had known that David was only going
to have 17 years would she have said yes
to doing this so if you know he had
wanted to go pursue something if he had
wanted to travel to do some he was an
artist if he had wanted to do some like
crazy art program and go you know would
she have said yes knowing that he only
had 17 years and so I'm the youngest and
it totally changed her perspective for
me and so obviously I don't think these
were easy decisions to say like all
right let me allow my child to go into
this room and pursue these things but I
was so so excited about it I was so
passionate and you know she and anybody
in your in my family would be able to
tell you that like my self-confidence my
personality it totally just blossomed
with being able to do performing but
hold that thought Brett of course the
daily wire is a hundred plus million
dollar company that probably spends
millions of dollars on video production
every year but it really shouldn't cost
that much to create high quality content
like if you're looking to get started
one of the best ways that you could
begin is with a software like a sponsor
stream yard stream yard is a live
streaming software that allows you to
create high quality content with the
click of a button all you need is a
camera and an internet connection to be
able to stream directly from your
browser and one of my personal favorite
features is that they allow you to
multi-stream which basically means that
you can stream to Facebook YouTube
LinkedIn and more all at the same time I
also really enjoy that streamer offers
various analytic tools so that you can
measure the success of every single one
of your live streams and you're able to
see which plan platform is bringing in
the most traffic stream yard is really
one of the best ways to get started
creating content without spending any
money whatsoever and they also offer a
free package so that you can get started
without any risk whatsoever check out
streamier today with our link Down Below
in the description on top of all of
those incredible benefits they've also
just been an amazing supporter of the
podcast and they help us do what we do
every Sunday for you guys so it would
mean a lot if you check them out with a
link Down Below in the description thank
you so much stream yard and back to the
podcast but yeah I signed with this
manager and so I started auditioning for
things on Broadway I ended up getting
the role of Jane Banks and it was going
to be coming in I had to come back for
one last meeting and the girl who's
currently playing the role her contract
was going to be up and there's a thing
on Broadway where if you are under the
age of 18 you cannot be taller I think
at the time it was like um you could not
be taller than five foot one because
from the back of the house they want to
make sure that you look shorter than the
adults that are on stage so you need to
look like a child
and I had a huge growth spurt over those
two months periods two month period so I
came back they measure you first thing
when you walk in the door and there's
the audition height
um and if you are taller than that you
can't audition and then there's show
height where they will literally end
your contract if you go if you get too
tall and so I had surpassed both the
audition height and the show height and
so that totally kicked me out of the
running for any other Broadway show
doesn't that make you really critical of
like your body at that age where you're
just like I hate it good enough like I
would stand there and I would like punch
myself down and I continued auditioning
for a few months after that like there
was the Revival of Annie that was coming
up I was way too tall for Matilda
Matilda was on Broadway Billy Elliott
had just closed it's all just a bunch of
like theater nerd stuff but there were a
ton of shows that had kids in them at
that time and I literally could not
audition for any of them how tall were
you I was like five two I think so I was
like barely over there but I was 10
years old and five too and so I was like
that was it okay and so I had this whole
management team and I remember going
into a meeting
and sitting down and they were like so
you can go home to Chattanooga and wait
until you're 18. you can wait eight
years and then you can start auditioning
for Broadway again you can just keep
doing the regional theater you're doing
you know we'll stick with you or if you
wanted to you could go out to LA and try
film on TV and my mom was like
absolutely not like she's from
California we talked about this in the
car
um she spent most of her adult life in
California prior to moving to Tennessee
she just wanted a different pace
um and she was like I'm not go every
time that she's left California she said
I'm never coming back even though she
was born in LA and I begged I was like
please like I can't just sit at home do
this and so I started auditioning
um via tape and so she was like let's
just see if there's any bites like let's
try you doing film let's get you in a
film class if you even like doing this
before we literally send you to LA to do
something
um I still loved it I started getting
callbacks for things and so we rented
out a friend's apartment in LA and my
mom and my dad and I drove across the
country did Route 66 and I lived there
with her for three months and I did like
every you know casting director Workshop
I did all of these acting classes I was
auditioning non-stop at a few
commercials I got a la management and
agency
and then from that point on for the next
four years I would spend six months at
home in Tennessee and then six months um
in Los Angeles so I'd go in the fall and
then the spring in L.A and spend the
rest of the time at home
um and I loved it it was like I mean it
was absolutely crazy and I feel very
very fortunate that I got the chance to
have a professional career at a young
age and I don't think that that's many
you know I don't think that's something
that many people would want yeah and I
definitely sacrificed a lot for it but I
loved it so much tell us about your
schooling at that time because how do
you balance the two so I was in public
school from kindergarten to third grade
my mom pulled me out in third grade
because my reading level was above that
of my class she had a meeting with
um my teacher and said could I give you
know could I give you some books for
Brett to read so that you know she stays
interested and it's not falling behind
or anything like that it's not getting
bored not being complacent in the future
set I just have too many students I
can't do it so my mom pulled me out and
she created the curriculum up until
sixth grade so you're homeschooled from
school third to six okay what is that
like for you like being pulled out you
liked it how are you making friends
through this whole process because
especially if you're like living in two
different states and then being
homeschooled how are you meeting people
in when we were still in Chattanooga and
I had not gone out to LA yet I was doing
ballet multiple times a week and then I
was a competitive gymnast so I did that
multiple times a week I was in a choir
so I met people through that every show
that I did I would make friends through
that you know friends in the
neighborhood that I still knew from
public school
um that is like the primary question
that anybody who's homeschooled gets and
some people you know hate it because
their parents did not go out and find
them extracurricular opportunities and
did not find them ways to be socialized
I literally would not change my
experience for the world I had the most
diverse group of friends because rather
than having you know one group of people
that you go through you know k through
eight and you go into high school or
whatever and it's you know the same
demographic from that same neighborhood
I was friends with people of all
different ages you know on my gymnastics
team from all different parts of town
you know boys and girls I'd interact
with adults constantly because I was you
know dealing with my ballet teachers my
gymnastics coaches and spent a lot of
time you know wherever my mom was
volunteering or my dad was working like
I would go and do school at his office
and so I was constantly interacting with
his secretaries and you know his
co-workers so at a very young age I
became Adept at socializing with adults
which I think is so beneficial and it
made me a lot more confident and you
know willing to network and start
working at a young age so I remember you
know being in high school and I wanted a
side job and so you know I would be
talking with my friends and say I want
to go you know apply this place and be
like you just go in and you talk to them
it's like yeah it's fine so I would go
into Trader Joe's drop off my resume go
to you know Lush Beauty drop off a
resume
um I was just so comfortable with it and
then on top of that with acting you're
constantly interacting with you know
casting directors directors producers
writers you know adult actors that
you're working with you're in a
professional environment you have to be
able to work at that level with child
actors they will give you some Grace for
being a kid but you also like they won't
hire you if you're a an idiot that's
like rolling around and being super
immature so you kind of have to up your
game
um so that is how I you know socialized
for those few years and then I did an
online private school but in this Online
private school you could still customize
your curriculum that's something my mom
cared very much about
prior to
investing in real estate and being a
stay-at-home mom she was a textbook
publisher of WWE Norton so she was deep
into Academia knew what she wanted me to
be reading knew what textbooks you know
she wanted me to be reading so
with my teachers she would work at the
beginning of the year and we would all
go over the curriculum and it was
usually tailored to things that I was
very interested in I'm a super super
heavy reader I love love literature and
so rather than reading you know six
books in a semester I was reading 30
maybe
um and what sort of books were you
reading just class literature primarily
okay and every week was like a different
you know we do American literature we do
it from this time period we would do
British literature I remember I think I
read Jane Eyre when I was 10 years old
for the first time oh my gosh here I was
reading Goosebumps I love those books
though
I had my uh Nancy Drew phase I think
I've read all like 55 Nancy Drews you
know
um but I had a very very academically
rigorous upbringing even though I was
also working and it all sounds very very
intense but I had so much fun
um and I loved it was worth for me you
know having to time block I guess and
time manage my school if I was going to
be on set and I would you know work on
it at night or you know on set you
usually have like a tutor and so they
would make sure that I was going through
all my schoolwork and I would have my
laptop there and be doing things and
that's what I did you know until
graduation except for one year I went to
a normal public school in Atlanta for my
ninth grade year what was that like
terrible absolutely terrible I I asked
to go
um my friends were going to this
performing arts high school and I knew
these friends from doing theater in
Atlanta and I went and I saw one of
their like school productions I was like
this is insane it was called Pebble
Brook High School it's one of the best
like public performing arts high schools
in the country I looked at my mom and I
was like I want to go here this is
insane like I want to try to be normal I
want to take a break from La for a year
I'll still audition but I want to go see
what this is like and I thought it would
be really really cool I hadn't sung in a
long time and so I could be a vocal
major and you know do all the musicals
so I auditioned we got a rental house in
Cobb County Atlanta and I went for a
year and within like two months I knew
it was not for me what'd you dislike
about it
I did not like that my time was dictated
by somebody else basically so I felt
like I was so unproductive which seems
absurd for like a 14 year old to be
saying in ninth grade I was actually I
think 13 in uh in my ninth grade year
because I graduated college at
teen I think 1920s why I think I was 13
12 turning 13 my freshman year of high
school
um and I hated that for six hours of the
day I was sitting in the classroom when
I knew because I'd been homeschooled for
so long I could get all of this work
done in a two-hour span like the busy
work I didn't need to do I didn't like
having to watch other people's hands
being held I didn't like the disruptions
in class
um and then I would stay late for dance
rehearsals musical rehearsals auditions
and that sort of thing and then I would
go home and because I didn't feel
academically unchallenged I went to my
counselor and I said can I do online AP
classes so my entire time there I was
doing a normal class load at school I
stayed an additional hour afterwards if
you were a magnet performing arts high
school or a magnet Performing Arts
student at the school you stayed an
additional hour and did like a dance
class of a class or whatever and then it
would often have rehearsals afterwards
and I would come home I would do my
homework and then I would do APK why
couldn't you have just dropped out I
know like it seems silly to me that you
were homeschooled for so long go for two
months I would just say let's go back to
homeschooling like what's what kept you
there because I made a commitment and I
wanted to read it through yeah well you
moved your entire
doesn't mean you have to commit like
what's the benefit of committing at that
point I would just say like you know
going through and being able to say that
I did it okay
um you know I made this commitment with
myself I wanted to try it I also wanted
to be able to say later down the line I
did go to I went to a public school I
tried it and I know both sides of the
story
um and I had also kind of fed into the
assumption that being homeschooled may
be weird
um and that I was off by that and I
wanted to see if normal high school was
like the movies basically depicted it I
wanted the Letterman jacket I wanted to
like go to homecoming do all that stuff
it just wasn't for me yes
um but it also was one of the because I
did all those extra AP classes and was
one of the best academic years for me at
13 years old I don't remember how many
people were in it was a huge school I
think it was maybe over 2 000 people
were in my freshman class I ended up
first in my class
um at the end of the year and so I was
really really proud of that
um
throughout the process so I'm still
friends with them
um yeah but I didn't
first semester I knew that it really
wasn't going to be for me but I wanted
to make the best of it I did every
musical I auditioned for everything I
tried to you know basically suck the
mirror out of life as much as I could
have
um but by the second semester I felt so
tied down and so unhappy that I hated
who I had become I felt like I was not
being a good friend people that I had
loved in the first semester I was I
didn't feel like I was treating them as
well I just felt very distant I wanted
to get out and I was so much happier
when I made the decision to leave and
now I'm you know still friends with them
we stay in contact and they went through
all you know three years but it was the
best decision I think for me to go and
learn that yeah I think it forced me to
kind of realize that what I was doing
was the right thing for me it was a
challenge for sure because it was a
different learning environment forced me
to adapt so I remember seeing home
school kids as a kid and they were
always kind of weird yeah uh that would
be my biggest concern of like ever doing
homeschooling is feeling like they're in
a bubble yeah but they don't get the
true experience they're not going to be
like out there kind of like forging
their own path what are your thoughts
about that I think it comes down to the
parents and sure how you dictate it
because obviously if you keep your kid
just inside and you don't facilitate any
other kind of extra quick Killers
they're not going to benefit from it but
the benefit of homeschooling is the
opportunities and the freedom and the
flexibility that you do have so if you
are in you know like my online school
that I went to I didn't have to finish
all my classes by a certain period I had
like nine months and so if I wanted to
get everything done in two weeks I could
have if I said hey you know I'm shooting
this movie I'm not going to be able to
do this for three months I can pick it
up later yeah
um you know with home I didn't go to uh
we try to co-op for a bit where you
would go you know Monday Wednesday
Friday for like two hours in the morning
and you would get graded didn't really
love that the opportunities weren't
great in Chattanooga but I had so much
flexibility so I was able to do
everything that I was interested in I
took art classes I did gymnastics I
volunteered and that was only because I
had the time to do it I was not you know
in school until 3 P.M I spent so much
time with my family I spent so much
quality time with my brothers my
relationship with my mom is one of the
things that I'm most proud of and we
really developed that over you know sure
that period I also think I inherited you
know this could be a benefit or a
drawback depending on whether people
like me or don't like me
um I inherited a lot of her values
because of that because I spent so much
quality time with her that she was the
one who raised me not a teacher and I
think that that is so important because
when you look at the statistics of how
much time kids are spending with their
parents these days I think that the
Department of Labor it's like 35 minutes
a day that's it yeah
but what age what is it we got to figure
out the parameters yeah so I need to
look at like what the actual you know
ages but when you remove like bathing
making dinner watching a movie together
like that kind of be like that because
that doesn't like actually quality time
when you are face to face with your kid
bonding doing an activity where you are
interacting yeah not just like sitting
in front of a screen or not like oh my
kid's in the same room but farther away
but like that's an average of 35 minutes
a day I I think that was in 2021 was
when you know I saw that stat that was
not the case for me like I mean I was
with them all the time whether I was at
my dad's office doing work whether I was
with her whether I was with grandparents
I spent so much time with family and I'm
very lucky that I you know love my
family
um but that's something that I also you
know do not take for granted at all but
I think that's something that parents
should be concerned about and obviously
you know depending on your you know
financial situation your job situation
might not be possible and obviously you
do need to consider you know the
education system the public schools and
that sort of thing in your area but it's
really taking into consideration like
who is raising your kid at the end of
the day who is spending that whether
it's the media whether it's teachers and
my mom didn't homeschool me because of
that but I think that is a result of
this she was never pulling out of school
because of an ideology or anything like
that it was simply because she wanted a
better education for me but by default
like I I think I
got a really incredible you know
physical education but also like
emotionally you know the interpersonal
side of it but why do you feel like
there's sometimes a stigma let's just
say if the homeschool kid goes into the
real world they go crazy they start
partying they do drugs they like get in
trouble uh why do you think that is and
what held you back from that again I
think it's those are usually the kids
that have not been pushed out in the
world at a young age have not been able
to take advantage of the opportunities
that you can usually have when you are
homeschooled
um and it's interesting because the
recent stats show that homeschoolers at
least in high school going into college
drink less do less drugs are not
Partiers and I think we're getting
better at that also academically our
scores are off the charts we're getting
into better schools the ivy league seek
out homeschoolers these days and so
again it goes back to the parents of if
you are making this decision you are not
only taking on your children's academic
life you are taking on their social life
and you have to remember that because
just keeping them in their house that is
why sure it's because they do not have a
social interaction you know they do not
have a social life outside of the home
and obviously you know spending time
with Mom and Dad is great but you have
to be around other people
um and so I think that you know you see
one side of homeschooling and that is
kind of the loudest group and people
oppose it for that group
um but I also like the smartest people I
know in my life are homeschoolers
because they you know Advanced so
quickly in their academic careers
because they started working at a very
young age they're incredibly
self-reliant and I think those are some
of the benefits but again it does go
back to the parents and so if you want a
homeschool but you are not in a position
to take all of that on it's like then
maybe they would be maybe better off in
some other school and if you're
concerned about academics try pipeline
maybe a public school or a private
school sure
um but it's really like I understand the
stigma because of that but I would also
push back on people saying that
homeschoolers are inherently weird
because I definitely was weird I like
was a total nerd I was a theater kid I
had a career
and I look at kids that are normal these
days and I'm so glad that I'm not one
like I'm very glad that I was not
partying I'm so glad that I did not
succumb to the same peer pressure that a
lot of my friends who you know grew up
in the normal school system did I was
totally oblivious to all of that I
didn't go through it
um I've had people say you didn't get
bullied so like you haven't been knocked
around no hell yeah I've been knocked
around like I had an entire acting
career like where I was told no 99 of
the time like my brother died my father
you know has serious mental health
issues I had enough like happened in my
life basically
um so I don't think that you are
completely you know exempt from bad
things happening or being toughened up
um so I guess that those are some of my
pushbacks against it but obviously
there's a reason why that stigma exists
there obviously are homeschoolers that
you know have come out that way sure so
what happens when you left public school
yes where did you go after that
um went back to LA was still splitting
my time between
um LA and Chattanooga started doing film
again I think it was like the next
summer I shot a fox miniseries called
shots fired so I was living in North
Carolina that summer doing a show
um that fall actually I emancipated
myself so I was emancipated at 15. why a
myriad of reasons
um I was about to shoot the second
season of a show it had been picked up
we didn't have a lot of details yet but
it was supposed to shoot in Prague and
at the time
my parents are going through their very
very messy divorce my oldest brother uh
this was mostly in my opinion due to the
death of his twin was my brother's wife
brothers who are identical twins and
Reed who was the surviving twin watched
David die and he is you know I don't
think ever really recovered for that I
don't know if you can recover from
watching ask what happened is that yeah
he had a cardiac arrest so they were on
the rowing machine and he just had a
cardiac arrest a rowing machine was that
was that like an underlying heart
condition like just at the gym yep at
school yeah and yeah
and the school didn't have
defibrillators and so they did CPR but
could not revive him uh what we think is
that he had something called Long QT
syndrome but we're not sure the autopsy
really didn't bring back much we didn't
want to just spend a lot of time doing
tests but I mean my whole family it's
crazy we don't we still really don't
know because Reed who is his identical
twin has no signs of it has never had
any signs of it and they are genetic
like genetically identical
and so truly the only one that has had a
sign of it is me like sometimes on my
EKGs because I do them yearly like
something has popped up that's kind of
weird but I think it's been alarming but
Reed has had no signs of it oh my God
but it's been 16 years since David's
death now
and read spiraled years after that so at
the time I mean he took he left college
and went to India for four years did
hard hard drugs and came back totally
different it was his way of coping my
parents tried to keep him from going
held money over his head my grandparents
gave him money and he ended up you know
going and it was just a whole you know
obviously a lot of turbulence I would
say
um and he really really struggled when
he came back and then he had a psychotic
break so my brother is now at this point
when I'm 15 he is diagnosed
schizophrenic yikes yeah I can't imagine
that with a twin because they hear a lot
of the times that there is that
connection between them
uh and I believe that I think and this
is like a part of yourself is is dying
at the same time and so you know when
you're growing up and there is I don't
know the psychological term for it but
therapists talk about it a lot where you
are you know moving into adulthood it
usually happens around College age for
us people in the Modern Age now but
where you break away from your parents
you start to see them as individuals
rather than as parents you defer you
differentiate yourself from your family
as you're creating your own family
you're creating new relationships you're
not living at home twins have to go
through that on another level with each
other because they spend their entire
lives like Reed and David did everything
together we're in the same exact class
lived in the same room they went to
boarding school lived in the same room
together had the same group of friends
looked exactly the same throughout their
entire life David would wear red red
wear blue so my Mom dressed them as a
baby they kept it up in high school but
it's like they were connected looked
literally identical
friends couldn't tell them apart they
had not at 17 years old had not gone
through that break and so it was like
literally this person instantaneously
was ripped away from my brother and he
was at an all-boys school and so at 17
years old had no Outlet he has often
said to me he was like Brad I cried once
and I was fine I was fine I promise like
it didn't impact me and it's like you're
bullshitting us like I know you did and
you don't need to do this for your
friends
um and so I think because he never
actually processed it it just you know
festered and festered and festered and
then he did a lot of drugs that
literally changed his brain chemistry
like he would do things in India where
he would wake up two weeks later in a
totally different part of the country
are you serious yeah
I mean he's done probably everything
yeah
um it came back was continuing to abuse
drugs got him in front of doctors and
then refused to take medication for and
you know I have my own thoughts about
you know antipsychotics and
antidepressants and that sort of thing
and I really believe that there are a
lot of Lifestyle diet changes that
people could make to help mitigate that
um and he did not want to do any of that
he said I don't have a problem I don't
have a problem and it's like you're
literally having psychotic breaks in
front of us
um and so he was at the time on the
street and he refused medication and
schizophrenics can often be violent so
my mom said you cannot live with us you
cannot live with your younger sister
um unless you were on these meds you
need to figure something else out so he
was like well I can get drugs on the
street so for two years he was homeless
and so I had this TV show that I was
possibly going to Prague for my parents
were getting divorced I got pulled into
the divorce at 15 years old I should
have been able to say like I want you
know I don't want to have to split
custody whatever
um and at the time I was like I have a
career I'm living in Los Angeles my
brother is a mess I cannot be dealing
with like my parents stuff in
Chattanooga right now I just I should
not be involved in it I kind of felt
like I started being used as a pawn in
it so I got a lawyer
um it was not going to lower it 15.
was it a publicly like they gave it to
you no I went and I found one in
Chattanooga so I did it in Tennessee
um but you just walked in with your
resume and yeah
I was still in L.A at the time but
because I was a resident of Tennessee
and my you know the learner's permit was
in that how do you pay for that I'd
imagine a lot of lawyers at that point
would just do it pro bono
um maybe in Los Angeles it's very very
difficult to do because a lot of
families will try to do that because
it's easier to be an actor if you are
not a minor because they don't have to
pay the additional fee right a tutor you
can work longer hours that kind of thing
so a lot of you know parents and
families and Stage moms and that kind of
thing will try to screw with the system
and like get their kid emancipated to do
it I didn't want to deal with that and I
was still resident in 10 see so we had a
couple of family friends my mom actually
helped me because I went to her and I
said I cannot be a part of this like you
know your intention you know your
attention to split between you know read
and you know being at home in
Chattanooga and she was going to move
read back to Chattanooga she was like
you're going to have to come and I was
like I don't want to I'm you know I'm a
professional I literally have a career
please just like let me try to do this
and so she was like okay
um so once again me like dragging my mom
along for this journey
but had I don't even remember he was the
father of a family friend of ours and
who's a family lawyer and so it was a
relatively like not a difficult process
but yeah I brought my resume showed the
money that I was making and I he said
you know it's not consistent enough
because acting's you know Ebbs and flows
so that was at the time when I got a job
at Trader Joe's so I was 15 got a job at
Trader Joe's worked there until 2021 I
kept that job throughout all seriously
yeah all throughout College how much
were you making at 15.
um 17 an hour that's really good that's
fantastic
awesome on it yeah and you get full
health care and all that so I got my
health care through them
um how do they hire you at 15 though
because in California you could start
working at 15.
if I could get my own insurance because
I was emancipated so I started working
there and I kept auditioning and then I
lived in La
um for a summer while my parents were
finalizing their divorce just in an
apartment in our apartment by myself
what did your parents say about you
getting emancipated did they have any
thoughts on that are they trying to stop
you from doing that or were they like
well you know you could make your own
decisions my dad was more concerned with
it my mom was on board because she did
not want me to be involved in the
divorce sure um you know I won't get
into details but it was my dad who was I
don't I'm not very close with him it's
kind of all I want water under the
bridge now but it's been a very very
difficult relationship at the time he
was the one that was pulling me into it
and I think it was kind of a power move
and so I went to him and I said this is
unacceptable and I said I'm doing this
because of the things that you are doing
and the impact you're having on our
family and I was like I'm not going to
blame my brother Reed right now but I
was like I just I cannot I physically
cannot be a part of this
um so if it's not contentious your
parents can both sign and if the judge
agrees that it's okay sure that it's
okay
um so that's ended up
being what happened so my parents both
agreed on paper and then it had to go to
a judge
um and then I was manipulated so I was
able to you know live in Los Angeles I
worked at Trader Joe's I kept
auditioning I kept doing you know
projects I did a couple of movies I did
a few other you know TV shows started
going to Community College
um because it worked better with my
schedule so I went to Santa Monica
Community College
it's a good school by the way yeah it's
a great school it's like has the best
transfer rate of any Community College
in the country
um my parents wanted me to go to SMC it
saves me money yeah it was great I went
to Community College I loved it yeah
Ventura College yeah then UCSB but yeah
um I say I would not change for the
world I feel like I got a better
education at SMC than UCLA like 100
honestly I would probably agree with
that yeah with my community college
experience because the classroom sizes
are a lot smaller it's more intimate and
also a lot of the professors like
Community want to be there yes because
it's more desirable to be a professor to
communicate with a lot of the times than
like the really nice science and at UCLA
you have to be doing research it's a
research University and so most yeah
that's in there the continuing education
or whatever it is yeah so UCLA is known
for its research and so a lot of the
professors there you know are you know
writing their own books in the English
literature Department you know working
on their Theses that sort of thing in a
community college they are there for the
students and you know again like the
through line with my life is I was
around a ton of different people and so
there would be people like me who were
younger there were people who were
coming me back you know 30 years later
working on their education I met the
most interesting people and in
California where it's very normal the
people go to Community College there was
not really a stigma but I mean truly my
education was better there and guess
what it was seven dollars yes seven
dollars seven dollars for a semester
yeah yeah how there's a California Bill
what's the point is what do you know
what I'm talking about seven dollars I
used it but it's only for the first
semester the next semester I think was
like a hundred fifth or something like
that but it's important in state yeah if
you're an in-state student
um I think it's also your district has
like a community college thing you have
to go to the according to uh Community
College yeah and then if you get
academic scholarships on top of that
because community colleges make money by
you know having the students there and
they want their you know stats to be
higher so if you're a really really good
student and you're coming here they make
it really desirable for you so I saved
so much money and it's totally flexible
because you don't have to be a full-time
student you don't have all those
premiums yeah exactly so I would do
night classes or you know 8 AMS and then
go you know audition in the middle of
the day and then go work up you know a 5
to 10 P.M to Trader Joe's and that was
my life so you went from that and then
you transferred to UCLA yeah okay two
years in I was a English major with a
minor in biological anthropology at
first and then dropped that because UCLA
if you are not already getting a BS you
have to do like chemistry and physics
for all of those things so I'm not
interested in that but I love
anthropology and I if I was more
scientifically inclined I would have
probably tried to do some kind of double
major but I did not want to do chemistry
did not want to do physics I just love
bio and I love anthropology anthropology
made more sense to me than any like
psychology or Sociology class I've ever
done and like understanding basic human
instincts and what we're like wired to
do it's like the perfect
I guess explanation for how even like
men and women are totally different like
we are literally wired different ways
um but anyway and so I did that for a
bit drop that minor and then was a fill
Miner until the end but I don't even
think I finished up my film minor
because I realized that I'd gotten to
the end of my major and it was in the
middle of covet I was like I don't want
to be on zoo anymore I'm just going to
dip
um but that was I probably did not
finish that minor because I went to the
UC Berkeley's Hospital of business and
they had a program where if you were an
undergrad you could go to their grad
school and do a business program so I
did that during covid and then as covert
was wrapping up I was at least in
California
um
I didn't really think I wanted to go
back to acting
um I didn't love the lack of control
that I had as an adult
um growing up as a kid it just was like
this crazy adventure and it felt like
this hobby that I happened to get paid
for I wasn't thinking about the money I
didn't see any of the money it all went
into a savings account and then legally
um with being a child actor there's a
thing called a Coogan account it's a
percentage of your money it goes there
so and my parents did not use any of the
money it just went into a savings
account so I used like part of that to
buy my first car and for you know some
of my UCLA tuition
um but I was ever motivated by money
because I wasn't getting like a slew of
American Girl dolls or anything like
that yeah it was just it was so fun for
me how much was in that Coogan account
by the way oh God do you remember
um is that a cruise now can you invest
within the account I don't think you can
invest with a network it's just cash
okay
like tens of thousands not nothing like
the phrase It's like a certain
percentage though yeah
I think it's 15 I don't remember what it
ended up being and it doesn't accrue a
ton of Interest it kind of just sits but
it's your legal protection in case you
are in an environment where your parents
are taking your money they want to make
sure that when you turn 18 you have
something and I think it's a great
production so I don't remember what it
you know how exactly much was but I know
I did my down payment for my first like
Kia Niro and like bought it with that
money and then paid some of my UCLA
tuition with it
um but yeah so I graduated and once it
became once the money part became a
little more close to home for me I was
like okay I'm about to turn 18 this is
like this is a career career and I
started thinking about like whenever I
get married and have kids because that's
always like the thing that I wanted most
is to be a mom
um my mom is and just an incredible
example of I think what a mother can be
and she just dedicated her life to being
a really really engaged parent I was
like that's what I want to do I want to
be able to like build humans I think
that's so cool and I was like I don't
really want to be a parent and be in
this unstable of an environment and I
really admire the people that are okay
with doing that but I also didn't like
that at the drop of a hat I could be
told to fly to North Carolina and it
would be something like okay you have
this audition at 4pm today tomorrow you
could be on a flight to Toronto and
shooting this thing you literally have
no control you have to say no to
everything in your life um that was
really hard for me as somebody that
really values control and having
autonomy over my life
I didn't love the fact that sometimes
you might Crush an audition and they'll
be like well you don't really look
enough like the person who's playing
your father you're too skinny you're too
fat we've Rewritten the role and you
don't fit anymore so we're firing you on
set or like here you've you know you
filmed the entire project we don't think
your role really reads anymore we're
cutting it and that so it's just like
constant and it's very very normal and
it comes with it so it's ever something
I really wanted to like try to change or
combat but it was like these are all
things that bother me and even though I
love storytelling I think I can do this
in another way so I went into production
so I did multiple like producing
internships at the end I was working for
big beach Productions they produced A
Little Miss Sunshine incredible I mean
one of the best internships I ever did I
learned so much
um but during covert we obviously went
virtual I hated that and then during BLM
and covid the entire industry just
became so political and my job became
less about find good stories and more
about could you find a Native American
story for us could you find a black
story for us like rather than just
reading scripts for the value in them it
was like we need something that is like
politically woke we need to be on the
cusp of this and I understood it because
that is what was making money at the
time that's what people wanted there was
a lot of pressure I was like okay now I
don't like this like that doesn't feel
authentic to me so I did what every
liberal arts confused graduate does and
I studied for the LSAT and I applied to
law school so I did that also during
covid I took the Tracy you just decided
on a whim be like no I'm just going to
take the LSAT yeah and so I was still
working still doing all of that and I
went back and I got my old act tutor who
also does LSAT stuff and I called him I
was like so buddy you wanna work with me
again
um and so I decided for that for about
nine months and then took that applied
for all the California schools I was
aiming for Pepperdine
um because I thought value-wise I would
be better than right that was the only
College I applied to is better really
yep and I said no
I didn't it was so that I was devastated
really yeah I've told the story it's
actually sad yeah what were you applying
for I well I wanted they I think had a
really good business program so I was
like I'm gonna go there for business but
I had terrible grades in high school
like really really really bad a horrible
SAT score I thought I would wow them and
just like write a great application do a
cool story because I was really into
like Reef aquariums and I was working
all through high school and I thought
like my resume kind of like a homeschool
kid yeah exactly but I was like I was I
was promoted uh in high school as the
assistant manager not the assistant
but the assistant manager of this whole
like reef aquarium place and I loved it
I'd worked there so I felt like I was
going to wow them and I applied and that
day okay that they were sending out the
acceptance letters going to Disneyland
and I was at the Blue Bayou in
Disneyland pulling up the email from the
first gen iPhone okay okay and I wait I
got the email in the morning but I
waited to open it at the Blue Bayou
because I thought to myself if I get in
we'll celebrate yeah and if I didn't get
in we're at Disneyland it's great and I
didn't get in oh my God the only School
you applied to how did it feel walk us
through your emotions uh
at that point I because I had no backup
plan well first of all I didn't know how
to pay for it like no one had so so
expensive so I didn't yeah so in my mind
it was like 40 Grand a year I had no
idea like no one in my family had money
to pay for that okay I think all of them
were gonna wow them with your reef
aquarium get a scholarship maybe get a
scholarship yeah
exactly something like that but uh yeah
I had no Back-up Plan okay
um and I thought maybe I could be a
drummer so because as I was in a band as
well in high school and I thought you
know maybe I could do this drum thing
like maybe it'll work out yeah uh but I
think like a month or two after I ended
up getting my real estate license that
was like my backup plan do that for a
year and then I could reapply okay but
that's what I was thinking about going
to SMC during that okay like maybe I
just take a year in SMC or I get my real
estate license yeah it was real estate
license
well that is so funny the dichotomy
between Brett's you know growing up and
Graham's growing up he's like Brett
would pivot in any direction should be
like success success success and then
Graham's like well like I don't want her
to be a drummer but who knows like Yeah
I wanted to make money worked out yeah
and I felt like I remember because we
used to play the right decision because
pepper 90 would have lost money oh yeah
Pepperdine would have been terrible yeah
drumming would have been interesting
though because there are now ways to uh
make money as a drama he's a good drama
he's a very good drama terrible yeah but
I would play shows on the Sunset Strip
you know like the Roxy and all those
places
Yes actually we've done all of them we
would do every single thing how did you
get because we were good and then they
were making something
yeah I can't believe it I love the Roxy
that's an incredible yeah I've been
there a few times it's an incredible
venue it's like iconic but we would have
to sell tickets you need to bring it so
this was
can I join
what would you do the triangle I'll do
it I could well I'll give you a backup
scene yeah I'd be a manager yeah I could
be this I could be the guy that like
brings the copies to everybody but now
here's the thing so we would usually
play like we wouldn't be like a headline
on a Friday or Saturday night so usually
we would be like a weekday night 8 p.m
and we would have to sell like 70
tickets between the three of us so we
each had like 25 tickets to sell and we
go around school be like dude they were
like 14 tickets and just like trying to
get people to buy tickets and then uh
the our bass player's mom would
sometimes just say oh buy the tickets
just hand them out no yeah so she would
sometimes you know pick up the slack
we'd just be handing him out it's all
about the hustle that is so cool that is
so cool I did not know you played at the
Rocks you know what's interesting too we
played a battle of the bands for
Southern California it was sponsored by
Coca-Cola we came in seven uh sorry
second place
second and technically it was a high
school competition
we lost to freshman college students
because they're bass players still yeah
you got it in high school but they were
like three years older than us and we're
really talented video about that man
yeah exposing this right back yeah but
if we won we got I think it was like
seven songs recorded for free plus a
trip to I think it was Scotland or
Ireland I forget what was there it was
one of those okay but we came in second
place to them I'm so upset but we went
through like we competed and then like
they ranked us and we go to the next one
and we'd like play again so I think it
was like four of them we lost two yeah
that is cool
I know
but uh but my point with being a drummer
was that I remember seeing such talented
musicians and they were broke yeah and I
remember seeing these drummers like on
stage and thinking they are incredible
like way better than I was and they had
been playing their entire lives and they
were broke yeah and I'm like if that guy
can't make it why could I like what
would make me different from that and
then I thought too if like the band
broke up and I was like on my own yeah
session musicians like a dime a dozen
it's very difficult it's a powerful
realization yeah like to have that at
18. yeah it's hard to walk away from
something that you're like especially
when it's something that's artistic that
you've literally like poured your heart
and soul I mean that's how I felt with
acting where it's like you come to this
realization that like logically on paper
especially if you're somebody that is
very like I consider myself a pretty
like rational person and like I have to
do what's practical it was like this
doesn't it doesn't make sense and so I
think for some people it not making
sense is what's so exciting about it and
I'm looking to do it regardless I was
never gonna be one of those people
graduated in 19. I was gonna go to
Pepperdine I applied to Pepperdine
Loyola UCLA and then one other oh
Chapman in California and then my mom
decided she was still living in
California at the time my parents had
totally slept my dad still in
Chattanooga
uh my brother was doing relatively
better at that point he was you know Med
compliant he was living in you know a
what you would call the living facility
but was like
a residency independent kind of thing
sort of before like psychiatrics we had
like a nurse there and a psychiatrist on
site but he was able to live like
semi-independently he was doing better
um but still he was so close to like all
the drugs that were on the street it was
really hard for him and my mom just did
not want to be in California anymore and
she had always had this dream of having
a farm and we'd always lived in rural
areas like Chattanooga we lived on a lot
of land I was actually born on an island
in Washington state where we had a farm
um so a lot of space there but she had
always wanted to have like animals and
huge Gardens and run a homestead and so
as I was getting older she was like all
right last one has totally flown The
Coop the other one seemed stable my
oldest brother has been great for years
he's totally fine
um been out of the house he's 14 years
older than me so he was long independent
so she started looking at Idaho because
I was going to stay in California and go
to law school my oldest brother was
thinking about
um moving up to Seattle to take a job
leave Florida go up to Seattle so he was
looking a job she was like this is great
I'll be like directly in between you
guys will be on on the same Coast read
my middle brother could either go with
her or could stay in his living
situation
um and then I said I just I can't do
California anymore I was like I don't
even really want to stay here I don't
really know why I'm staying here other
than for acting I just can't do it and
so I moved to Boise with her and lived
there for nine months helped her get her
Farm started got a house there started
settling in I got a job as a marketing
strategist at Young Americans for
Liberty which is Ron Paul's former
organization so very libertarian I was
writing for the foundation for economic
education which is the longest running
free market think tank so I was doing
like economic journalism for them
um and was like fully leaning into this
because I had already during covid I
started working with prageru
I just kind of struggled with
friendships due to political reasons at
UCLA during covet it just got so
polarized and I just a lot of it how did
that begin though did you start bringing
up maybe certain viewpoints and getting
so when did you recognize your political
leaning
um
I would probably say the beginning of
college but I didn't really even think
that it was that important I just kind
of realized as I would look at news
stories and you know talk to people I
was like oh okay I think that this is my
opinion I guess that this is political
in nature it was just you know values
I've been raised with are things that I
just intrinsically thought and I started
kind of connecting the dots with
politics and being like Oh okay so if I
believe this and that means this
um slowly started formulating all of
that
but I was not raised in a political
household by any mean my mom is a
student of objectivism she adopted Ein
rand's cat after she died she spent
years yes so I mean she you know was in
textbook publishing was you know always
more you know Freedom leading I would
say
um my older brother is very libertarian
um and so but we were not raising a
political household like my mom would
listen to Rush Limbaugh in the car when
my oldest brother was young but like I
never heard any of that I never listened
she never listened to Ben at most maybe
she would pull up a Dennis Prager you
know radio show like once every year
maybe or something like that we never
discussed politics ever I had no idea
what my dad believed other than he loved
the environment I mean truly had no idea
and I honestly think that's
I'm so grateful that that is how I was
raised because it was all based on
values it was like how you treat people
how you see the world like you
intrinsically value Freedom you value
individualism you and you know you Value
Independence people not telling you what
to do the government not being involved
in your life but it wasn't even the
government it was just kind of you know
free thinking independent
those are the values I was raised with
so as I started being confronted with
politics I was like oh okay this makes
sense I'm seeing the connections but was
not right we literally never talked
politics whatsoever and I didn't even
know that Iran was a how did she get her
I I had yeah she left in the middle of
the night after graduating college my
grandmother wanted her to go to
secretarial School my mom said
absolutely not so she left with her best
friend from college they drove to New
York City in the middle of the night and
she was like I'm going to get a job as a
textbook publisher and her friend had
some connections I think through college
they're still good friends I literally
saw him a couple of months ago
um he's a wealth manager now like a free
market wealth manager so he's helped me
with some stuff
um but he had some connections I believe
it was through their college that went
to Davidson College
um with people in Iran's Circle and her
to proteges who now run her like two
biggest organizations after her death
you know published her books with her
like that sort of thing got in contact
so they started going to these like
philosophical salons and getting
literally trained and philosophical
lessons from these proteges and Ein Rand
died soon after my mom moved to New York
work her cat Tommy named after Thomas
Aquinas because Thomas Aquinas was the
only person to argue the existence of
God for a place of reason and even
though Iran was like totally atheist she
respected people who were arguing the
existence of God from a place of reason
because reason was Paramount to her
reason you know healthy selfishness and
productivity you know the biggest things
for objectives really in my like boiled
down sense I guess
um and so Tommy needed a home and so
they were like Diane can you take
einrant's cat so she had Iran's cat she
lived in a tiny room that didn't even
have a kitchen or anything like that she
worked night shifts at a hotel doing
like the the call person
um works like three jobs and finally got
in the door with ww Norton and she
published the first objectivist like
libertarian textbook and it's still
published today
um so she did that and then lived in
Chicago for a bit doing it but
anyways
no today we have been on the exact same
wavelength we just go hmm that's the
exact same but not only that but other
words
at the exact same time the same phrase I
don't know we spend a lot of time
together at the same time you guys went
like this I know yeah
okay all right but anyway so that is how
I was raised to the value I was raised
but I appreciated that it was not
political because I you know I've had
people say like you're you know your
mother indoctrinated you and I was like
well what would you say would be
indoctrination like I was not you know
being told about political policies or
anything like that she just raised me as
any good parent would with the values
that she believed were important to
create a you know a healthy independent
young person and those happen to be
these more you know
I would say objectivist libertarian
Freedom leaning whatever anyway so that
is how I I guess started seeing that and
obviously with covet it became very very
politicized but even before that at the
end of 2019 beginning of 2020 midterms
it became a huge topic for people and I
had already noticed some tension because
people knew that I was originally from
Tennessee and that was something that I
didn't think was contentious but
apparently it was and so being from
Tennessee yeah and it was like you're
from the south you're backwards you're
racist and I remember my friends being
super drunk at a party and I walked in
and one of them said there's our racist
friend Brett from Tennessee and we
hadn't even talked about politics yet
how does that make you feel it was just
it was stupid to me and but I still
thought that they were good friends I
remember coming home you know calling my
mom or calling my brother and be like oh
yeah they said this it's so funny and my
brother would be like that's not
friendship right like what those are
just random attacks like why are you a
lying that happened I was like oh
everybody you know you know shoots the
[__] it's fine
um and they would insinuate other things
like we'll be talking about our families
I would say oh yeah well my you know my
dad's side of the family is all for
North Carolina old like dirt poor
farmers and they you know fought in the
Revolutionary War
um so I guess could be part of like
Daughters of the American Revolution I
think my like great grandfather like
fifth grade grandfather fought in the
Revolutionary War but like dirt poor
tobacco farmers and we were talking
about our lineages because most of my
friends were in this friend group you
know one was Turkish one was Indian
we're just talking about ancestry and
when I said like farmers in North
Carolina they were like oh so your
family owned slaves
and I was like how did we get there and
I was like I it just said so I blew it
off but I think that's kind of how it
started and I fought back against that I
was like we were literally I we didn't
like I would know and even if it you
know even if my family did how does that
impact you know the person that I am now
and the friend that's sitting in front
of you
um and so that's kind of where it
started that was even before all of you
know the midterm started and all of that
and then midterms I believe it was no no
it wasn't the terms it was primaries
primaries
um for the presidential election
um and so then obviously there were a
lot of conversations about like Bernie
and Joe Biden and that sort of thing and
I knew enough at that point and I was
like clued in enough to know I don't
really think that I would vote for
either of those I wasn't like rah-rah
Trump I never really have been
um but I did not hate him I didn't
understand the vitral about him
um and so people started bringing it up
to me and saying so like who are you
gonna vote for I was like I don't really
don't know like maybe I'll vote for you
know Joe Jorgensen she's like the
libertarian I don't really know I said
but I don't I don't love Joe Biden I
don't love Bernie Sanders and I mean
they lost their [__]
um and it just became like a huge
argument and debate constantly I
remember you know all of us voting in
the primaries and me not voting for
either Joe Biden or Bernie and them
being very very angry one of my friends
voted for for Joe instead of Bernie her
father was a policeman and she thought
the Bernie was just like a little too
much and she got slandered because she
wasn't far left enough and that was my
my big and my sorority and I remember
thinking like why is this such an issue
issue like this is crazy and then Cove
had happened
um and I remember friends you know
making me riding a car by myself like
six months in because it's like well you
know you're on the right so obviously
you don't care about covets you can't
you know hang out with us because you're
probably like not taking things
seriously I was like well no it's still
a I wasn't even thinking that it was
political at the time even though I
didn't think that lockdowns economically
were going to do anything good for this
country I thought that it was 100
government overreach
um BLM started taking off and I stayed
out of that for most of it until it just
kept continuing on and seeing the way
that businesses were then you know
taking steps for racial action and all
this stuff and I was like I think that a
lot of this is you know blown out of
proportion and why is the media lying
about what's actually happening like I'm
living in La I'm seeing these protests
it's totally different than how they're
painting it but the kicker for me was
and this is why I left La there was a
business in Burbank that got taken away
from the owners because they stayed open
during the second lockdown of covid and
they didn't even stay open completely
they left their patio open and it wasn't
any kind of like political Fu or
anything like that they left it open
people could sit on the patio and enjoy
their takeout food whatever
got reported to the city council went on
for nine months
um their electricity was turned off the
you know
the business was boarded up was chained
up multiple times and then it became
personal for the owner and he's 22 and
he inherited it from his father he
became a really good friend of mine his
name is Lucas lepagean and then you know
yeah the whole Community rallying behind
him he would break through the doors
every time he would open it back up
Community donated generators um they
kept shutting down electricity so he
just had grills and his staff kept
coming back to cook and then you know
policeman on their days off would come
and like protect it and that sort of
thing like it was it was wild
um got tons of donations he was arrested
I think four times multiple multiple you
know City Council meetings about it and
the kicker for me was
there was one last city council meeting
with public comment and I think public
comment went on for like four hours and
you know I called it everybody was
calling in and this was going to be the
determining factor of whether they could
keep the business open and what it looks
like was going to happen was that they
would have to shut down for two weeks
you know pay their due diligence pay the
fine to they had accrued and then open
back up because at this point every
other business in La was open like you
could go inside and eat except for this
one except for this one and by the end
of the city council meeting everything
seemed fine they were like all right
we'll get back to you tomorrow in the
middle of that while public comment was
going on the City of Burbank sent out a
construction crew and they built a wall
around the business a 10-foot barbed
wire with like the what do you call that
I guess that is the bar bar so it was
chained like barbed wire on top 10 feet
so they literally could not get into the
business all their you know they were
paid up on their taxes they were paid up
on everything they owned this building
I think they'd owned it for two
generations it was two generation
business
from Burbank had was like a staple in
the community and they totally I mean
literally just took it from the owners
in the middle of public comment and I
was like
so I'm living in a place where the
government can literally come in and
take your home take your business
because they disagree with something
that you've done and not listen to the
community members that are literally on
the phone for hours
did they take the business though or is
it more they're just deterring people
from going inside that sounds like the
fence is more just like basically what
it is um and saying that you you know
the business owner cannot operating
right so you you know you must shut down
basically what it was
um I think the building has been
demolished now
um You just sold it well I'm guessing
what was the verdict of the the hearing
that they it was just gonna be shut down
but they made that decision before so
they said oh we'll come back tomorrow
and so Lucas woke up the next morning in
the house and the the restaurant was
totally surrounded
so it was so they basically just wanted
to punish him for his past yeah exactly
yeah
um and the guy who did that who led that
was a Burbank city councilman who ran um
in the DSA party so he was a Democratic
Socialist of America ran on that party
was elected as such
um and that was a kicker for me and then
during in the middle of 2020 LAPD also
slashed a huge part of their Major
Crimes unit which included the sexual
assault unit which included the gang
unit and as a woman that really freaked
me out because I already knew that I
couldn't defend myself with a gun I'm
trained with guns I've shot my entire
life
um and you know I spent a lot of time in
the city by myself I started doing
self-defense training when I was 11
years old because my mom was concerned
about me going into audition rooms with
you know adults by myself because
obviously the casting couch is a real
thing we know about the metoo movement
which was like I never want you to feel
insecure about that so I did that for
seven years every single week you know
helped teach self-defense I was a very
very competent person still am
um and part of that was because you know
as adults she knew like you're not going
to be able to carry a gun in this city
you're not gonna be able to protect
yourself but they took away that extra
level of protection the LAPD response
time dropped like crazy
um gang presence in Burbank started
skyrocketing again in the span of like
two months there were three shootings
and two stabbings in my like one mile
vicinity alone which had never happened
before
um and I just felt totally unsafe and so
my mom was leaving for Boise and I was
like I don't really know if I want to be
here alone I don't like this I don't
like the values that are around me why
would I stay in a place that you know
does not value my security or safety and
where the government is so willing to
punish you for having a differing
opinion
um I was like I don't think this is
where I really want to start my adult
life I can do it somewhere else and so I
was like I'll figure it out I'll go to
Boise I loved it I loved her Farm I
loved the remote work that I was doing I
got into Boise's law school so I was
going to do a dual MBA and JD program
just four years I wasn't sure what I was
gonna do with it I thought I would
probably go do constitutional law
specialize in 2A which was what I was
really interested in
and then I actually met over the summer
with a bunch of constitutional liars and
they said don't do it you know like
you're gonna make no money it's a waste
of money because unless you're going to
one of the top top schools and you're
going into corporate law you will make
no money you're going to waste five
years four years because I was doing two
programs
um and they said you know you're already
working in politics you're doing
adjacent basically you are you know
making videos for prageru you you have
this marketing strategist job at another
organization you're writing you're doing
journalism you have the connections now
you don't need to go to law school to
make those connections you can do
advocacy and the exact words he said was
you can do everything we can do except
sign the brief why would you go to
school for four years just to do that
and go into debt because I got somewhat
of a scholarship for it but I was still
gonna have to pay a lot of money for it
um and if you look at the discrepancy
between the amount of legal jobs that
are available in the amount of law
schools it's just insane I mean we are
pumping out so many JD students and
there are not enough positions I think
the base salary for a law student that
did not go to like one of the top five
is like in the 65-75 right that's not
that much plus laws I believe the
unhappiest career yeah and I'm such a
creative person the people in my life
are like oh this doesn't make sense but
I was like I'm smart like I am academic
I can make a difference I want to fight
for this I was really politically
engaged at the time and then the day
that orientation started I was like I
can't you're all right I can't do it
yeah so I went through I had no plan I
was doing that journal writing a fee I
was being a marketing strategist and I
was a waiter at a restaurant in Boise so
I was doing all three of those I left
Trader Joe's and I was like I'm just
gonna figure it out and my mom was like
you just blew up everything basically
you need to figure it out I was like oh
I'll come up with a plan so I was in the
process of coming up with a plan I was
still making video videos for prageru
for Young Americans for Liberty I was
running all their social media accounts
when I got a DM from daily wire and they
said we've seen your short form videos
we love your content would you be
interested in having a meeting with us
and I thought it was a joke and I was
like this can't be real
So I responded and I was like okay and
I've respected the daily wire for a
really long time it actually looked and
applied for jobs with them I applied to
be Candace owens's assistant you're a
prior yeah and her manager rejected me
before I didn't even do an interview
which she knows now she thinks is so
funny that was the reason for the uh
rejection I didn't live in Nashville oh
yeah she didn't even respond because
they were only looking at people that
were in Nashville make sense okay but I
was like I'll move my researchers like
I'll move I'll move um and it was funny
because her manager and I her ex manager
and I are now like friends and I like
was messaging her I worked out for a
reason yeah exactly
um I applied for like an associate
producer role on Ben's show in Florida
like I was like I just I want to be
involved in this company somehow because
I loved what they were doing in the
entertainment sector and I was like I
could get back into storytelling where I
my values are more in line with what
they're doing and that could kind of
give me the balance that I'm looking for
and I could be on the production side so
I would have more control and a little
more stability which is also what I was
needing
um and so I wanted that but I also in
the back of my head thought you know
this organization is skewed older all
the hosts are older you know it's a bit
more established I don't know if they're
going to want to be hiring I was 19 at
the time a 19 year old kid to do any of
this I was like you know what I will
continue working at Young Americans for
Liberty which is a student organization
prageru really focuses on students and I
was like I'll stay here for a few years
I'll apply again later on and maybe I'll
you know get my foot into the door with
daily wire or maybe I'll go back to
acting I don't know I'll just you know
leave it up to whatever happens so I got
this DM I was like you've got to be
kidding me this is insane respond back
we start emailing back and forth I do a
zoom call
um really like the people
um all of them still work here except
one you guys met the girl earlier who
sent me the DM yep and she was just
scrolling on she ran the tick tock
account and found me and here we are but
um then they said you know you only do
short form content we'd like you to do
like I did reactions and like my
reactions to news stories and that kind
of thing and they said could you do like
longer responses to news stories and
then could you also show us like maybe a
pop culture thing and I said okay so I
did that and then they hired me
I was you know I think we negotiated for
about three months I had I found out
that I got the job while I was in the
field with my mom in her pasture like
wrangling a donkey or something like
that and I got a call from our CMO and I
was grilled for like an hour and what
what did that sound like
um it was basically like are you you
know we're taking a risk on a 19 year
old kid and we're gonna bring you here
and we're gonna try to create something
with you we want to make sure that
you're not some like fluke and so it was
basically like I've seen your resume the
people below me are advocating for you I
want you to tell me why you deserve to
be here and I was like shaking I was
like standing up in my mom's bedroom
shaking and it was like how are you
different than other 19 year olds like
this is and daily wire is like very very
hustle oriented we are constantly you
know you know we're past startup mode
but we are growing so fast every single
day like you'll see Jeremy boring
speeches about the fact that this is a
an objectively a hard place to work
because we do so much we pump out so
much content every single day and the
benefits I think definitely outweigh the
fact that it's a lot of hard work so I
think we're doing really good things and
I'm really proud of everything that we
do but they wanted to make sure that my
ambition and that my you know hustle and
what I was willing to take on matched
what they were going to be expecting and
if they're going to take again take a
risk on a 19 year old
um ended up working out I guess I did a
good job I remember coming in and
meeting that guy and literally being
like I'm so like I hope it worked like
whatever
um and then I
you know I think that was solidified at
the end of November I had 10 days to
move I fought with them I was like
trying to be able to start in the first
of the year but they were like we really
want you here now to get started on
developing the show now why didn't you
decide to go off and do that on your own
because you could have just as easily
said okay you know I could make YouTube
videos I could make tick tocks and
shorts I'm doing it already why have the
management of the daily wire the
mentorship yeah
um and I've said this before the value
of being in this building where I am
next to Candace Owens Ben Shapiro Matt
Walsh Michael Knowles Jeremy boring
Jordan Peterson where I get to interact
with these people often on a daily basis
is immeasurable to me like that is truly
Priceless
um and I feel like you know they have
been very very gracious with you know
and I talked about this couple of weeks
ago of you know as the shown has grown
they have you know changed my
conversation like that kind of thing
like they are very very proactive with
making sure that you know the talent is
supported and that sort of thing but I
would literally
be fine with barely being paid and being
being here because the things that I am
learning not only about how to navigate
this space but also on an intellectual
and an ideal ideological level from
these people who all have very very
different opinions like if you watch the
backstage events the daily wire does
here you will see the differing opinions
of all of the hosts and the fact that we
all get to be here and work and debate
and go back and forth and still respect
each other and still you know support
each other's shows it's I mean truly
Priceless
um
and I knew that I was not going to get
that anywhere else and it felt like this
was just an incredible opportunity and
in my head I was like if I hate it I can
leave in a year because I wasn't signing
on a multi-year anything at the time I
was just coming to try a show and I was
like I hate Nashville I always have a
backup plan I had house in Boise I can
come back I can go to law school again I
can try to do something else to go back
to acting whatever
but I was gonna kick myself if this
didn't happen but I almost didn't do it
I almost didn't even send in the longer
reaction they were asking for because I
was so nervous
and I don't know what it was I was so
insecure I hadn't acted in a really long
time and it isn't acting but it's still
like putting yourself on it's a
presentation yeah exactly and I hadn't
been judged in that way in a really long
time I just been doing my like stupid
little like minute long videos and my
I mean it's weird to say it was like
growing considering where I am now but
you know I started a new Instagram and I
think by that point I had like 7 000
followers which is still like for I was
not really producing it right and I was
like okay I'm doing this and it's fine
um and I just I kept pushing it off and
I was like I'm just so scared I'm so I
just don't know if it's right I don't
really want to do it like I loved Boise
and I was like I'm happy here I'm happy
working on your farm I'm happy with this
house and this life I've created and my
mom literally sat me down and looked me
in the eyes and she was like I don't
care if you take the job or not but you
are going to kick yourself in five ten
years a year if you do not send this in
if you don't at least try and she was
like your entire life you've taken all
of these risks you have literally been
like balls to the wall sending letters
to managers like showing up emancipating
or whatever you're doing like going and
doing a business program applying for
law school like you pointed out like I
literally would take any risk and just
do it because it sounded interesting to
me and if I hated it then hell at least
I have a good story about it
um going to public school and she was
like I don't know what has changed over
the past year and I think that I kind of
felt like a a beaten dog in a way sure
like after covet I'd lost most of my
friends I left la which is all I knew I
wasn't acting anymore I think I just
lost all my confidence and she was like
this is an incredible opportunity for
you and it is also incredible
opportunity to just get back on the
horse try something you're literally a
waitress right now like you have
literally nothing to lose I was like
fine you're right Diane's usually right
so I set it in they loved it anyway I
came here and then I was here in
December and they we developed the show
together and it launched a year ago
yesterday wow yeah it's crazy you've
done all of this in a year yeah I keep
thinking you've been doing this for like
five years
that's insane so like two million
subscribers one year I think how many
did you get in the first four months I
think it was like 700 000 subscribers in
a few months we I hit a million in six
months we're in five months what was
that like for you and where did that
audience come from was that Ben's
audience navigating over to you because
maybe there's a bit of a resemblance or
is it initially yes so we did not do any
paid ads for my Channel at all
um in fact we did a very or daily wire
did a very very soft marketing campaign
like there was barely anything I
remember in my pitch with Jeremy when we
like brought the show in front of him he
didn't even know really who I was at the
time and the CMO had brought me on and I
was like hey I'm the political kid
that's here trying to you know get a
show approved and he watched the pilot
which was so bad and he looked at me and
he said I don't understand the show it's
not for me but I know it's for somebody
else it's not really for our audience
but I know it's going to reach somebody
else so let's try it and I mean
literally through us like a few grand to
put together a set
took some team members from like our
social media video team and we're like
just try it and see what happens
um so I did my own promotion on my like
social video Channel or my social media
channels and I had been doing like some
daily wire videos like news hits and
that sort of thing so I think I was
probably up to like 20 000 like
followers okay one still didn't have a
YouTube channel so there were some
people who knew who I was in the daily
wire Circle and then I did one hit on
Ben's show and announced the show and
that was it I don't think any of the
other hosts talked about it Candace
didn't even know that I had a show or
who I was for like six months because
nobody told her yep
um we literally it was like a trial and
error they did not put any paid or
anything
um so I think some of it migrated over
and you know daily wire would repost me
every once in a while so I think the
initial like bulk I would say maybe
under a hundred thousand came from the
daily wire audience
um but then it's just been
where did the rest come from was that
just a series of videos that you posted
that did well yeah what was the in
shorts shorts yeah okay I mean we that
was not something I really knew a lot
about but I was already doing a ton of
organic content for Instagram and Tick
Tock and so that made its way to YouTube
and one thing I think I've done
differently is that all of my shorts
content was original it wasn't clips
from the show it wasn't anything like
that it was all like this is designed
for yeah YouTube or before YouTube In
the Beginning how did you pick topics to
talk about is this on you or would they
would they come to you and it still is
on me still so I create the show I pick
the topics I pull all the comments if
there's anything that I want to write
sometimes it's off the cuff
um these days I'll kind of have like
bullet points of points I want to hit if
there's a message that I want to leave
people with sometimes I'll write that
out if it feels a little more touchy but
it still is pretty improvised and I just
researched the subject really well and I
try to become an expert on that like one
little thing every day
and then share it so I still do all of
that but it was basically just living on
social media and it still is and so most
of my content is social media heavy I
will only cover something if it is like
trending on social media or if I notice
that it's about to so that can mean like
literally trending on Twitter or if it's
a trend on Tick Tock that is like
picking up or a
the thing in society that has you know
whether it's a social media Trend or
just a trend in general in the original
sense of the word um
and so I would find things through there
and then you know it's called the
comment section that was kind of the the
get of the show and the angle was that I
wasn't just like talking about a subject
just my opinions but I was going into
the comments and actually trying to get
people's actual opinions about it yeah
so I'd get people on both sides of the
aisle on both you know sides of whatever
issue I was talking about and read those
comments it was fun to you know kind of
act them out and use my act you know
acting background to make it really
really fun
um and then I wanted it to be really
really Punchy because I know my
generation I know that I hate watching
long form content because our attention
spans are dead due to tick tock so it
was very very fast paced so I wanted
like memes like we had our first you
know editing run it was like we need
more it was like more cowbell like more
memes like more Fast Cuts I hate that
yeah but it works I mean that's like
that's what my generation means it's
like I need my attention yeah I'm saying
he always rejected my own tick tocks
like sound effects sound effects zoom in
that's what I love over here sound
effects sound effects
yeah for young people it's what we are
text on screen yep you gotta have so
many things flying
so we we really like worked very hard on
creating that you know that style and
then I wanted you know the comments were
kind of a unique thing and then
obviously that I was going to be you
know more right laning was a different
thing because there wasn't really
anybody in that space that was doing
this kind of like laid-back cultural
commentary streamery type stuff it was
really on the right that was my age yeah
because it's like there's a lot of them
that are you know 35 year old dudes but
like an 18 year old girl like that's not
really the normal right that's right
um but yes it was on social media
primarily and I started off doing more
newsy political things I strayed away
from that just because
have gotten far more disinterested in
that
um why did you lose interest
because
I obviously think that politics matter
and I'm interested in politics on like
an academic and intellectual level I
think it's interesting I care about
learning about it but Andrew by um but
Andrew Breitbart once said and I think
it still holds weight
um that politics is Downstream from
culture and so it starts with culture
and the conversations that we're having
every single day and it starts with
values and that's how I was raised
that's what I care about I care about
you know looking at Trends on social
media and saying why why is this
something that people care about
um and I think that we can talk about
you know social media trends and
cultural things and movies and TV in
Hollywood without a political angle but
just talking about like what is driving
these people to believe this way and in
my mind a lot of that goes back to like
my current critique with my generation I
would say is that it's driven by this
desperate need for both attention and to
victimize themselves
um I think that victimization is holding
most of my generation back
um I think we hold ourselves back a lot
of the time
um and we know that being a victim these
days does give you more attention and so
it's things like that where it's like
I'm not directly talking about politics
and theory and like this new law but I'm
talking about things that do by default
influence politics and I also think that
talking about things that are more
cultural and are more value-based number
one they interest me but I think that
it's it's easier to connect with people
on a human human level that way it's
less polarizing I get that um I can have
so much more empathy with people and I
think people find me more relatable
because of that and when I'm talking to
people who are on opposite sides of
political aisle that is where we find
the most common ground is by talking
about this and then being able to say
like oh okay so now I see why you think
that the way you do you know because of
this value that you hold or because of
this you know let's talk about in the
context of culture
um and you're able to reach so many more
people and you're able to find so much
more common ground
um and I think it makes my content maybe
more digestible for people I would say
because it doesn't come across as like
I'm gonna hit you over the hammer let's
talk about Trump let's talk about Biden
it's like but then you think it's also
easier to talk a little bit more about
like drama topics or maybe topics that
hit on a more emotional level exactly
logical yeah and people are driven by
emotion these days and I've said this
publicly before on the show and I love
Ben and you know he's a mentor of mine
and I think you know fact don't care
about your feelings such a fun Punchy
line but I think especially with my
generation they don't really care about
facts it's like emotions are dictating
so much now whether that's better or
worse that's something we can all relate
on that's the human human connection and
obviously facts are important at the end
of the day but if you can't reach
somebody emotionally whether that's a
positive emotional or a negative emotion
like facts will go out their ear they
don't care and especially in a time when
we see so many you know whether it's you
know scientists or politicians the media
lying about facts or changing them like
literally just you know saying outright
lie or get you know getting the facts
changed in order to fit an agenda or a
narrative it's like okay so then if
they're doing that then how do we reach
people yeah with emotion and that also
as like somebody who comes from like an
acting in a storytelling background and
why I loved acting so much in addition
to it being an escape was that it
allowed me
to tap into the emotions that I was too
scared to deal with as a child and was
too scared to feel or Express and so I
really really understand the importance
of connecting to people on that level
and reaching people at that level
um and so it makes me happier too and so
as a content creator I feel more
fulfilled in what I'm doing because I
read my comments and it's less about
people you know being fired up about
some political policy or being angry at
Joe Biden which gets so tired so I don't
want to talk about him anymore it's
boring I do I don't want to talk about
Trump anymore whether it's positive or
negative it's boring
but hearing people's anecdotal stories
and the way that they are emotionally
responding to things in the world right
now is really interesting to me and you
really understand where people come from
um and so I think that's why I'm able to
connect you know what I grew up doing my
career prior to this and what I'm doing
now I think it kind of fuses together in
a really really nice way yeah it's a
really interesting quote that politics
lie Downstream from culture yeah I
actually completely agree and recently
actually I shouldn't say recently I'd
say probably about a year ago I became a
lot more disinterested in politics
growing up I was kind of interested in
it and I had gone to like some political
meetings and stuff like that growing up
and then you're laughing a year or so
ago I realized it's kind of worthless
it's kind of useless like a lot of the
times like you said it's just all filled
with vitriol and you can't really focus
on like bigger picture things like
hating on certain people yeah it's
mostly on like incidental anecdotal with
one person yeah um and also on top of
that what I noticed is that
conservatives and liberals and I could
get blamed for this I actually have a
lot more in common in terms of values
like core values uh than people think
yeah and a lot of the times the values
are just mass by culture and certain
like Frameworks of where you grew up how
you grew up and stuff like that the
value systems are very very extremes on
both sides and those are you know that's
what gets the attention yes exactly and
and a lot of times you know those you
know very you know polarizing sides like
obviously they get very angry at each
other and it's important to talk about
them because those obviously feed into
the masses but I think if you find like
commonplace people on the street they
will have things in common and I think
they get pulled in either direction and
they feel like they have to have
allegiance to like okay this really
intense crazy side this really intense
crazy side I think it's important to
show people that it's like it's okay to
have common sense if I could say that
like I could boil down my content into
like one word it would be common sense
and it's like I just want to have a
place where you can you know laugh where
you can feel like the world isn't too
crazy on either side you know what's
funny that could be your second Channel
we were talking about this earlier
common sense with Brett Cooper there you
go yeah
sense yeah that works with so many great
ideas I know he's been like yeah
even for the sponsor earlier I'm like
you gotta get a sponsoring yeah exactly
um but no and I think that that's
something a lot of people are missing
these days because that is an inherently
political and I think what you were
saying about it being worthless is that
especially as a young person I mean you
probably relate to like gen Z there's a
reason why we feel so hopeless all the
time like the world is just filled with
fear porn that everybody's telling us
the world is like burning around us or
you know we're you know born into 9 11.
I mean all of this stuff like it's just
like but there is a reason for that
because that's what gets the clicks yes
and so of course it's going to feel and
it gets people super angry and that sort
of thing but we live in a very we have
grown up in a very strange world where
we're the most digital of any generation
before and so that's a totally new thing
it's like very very heated and polarized
um and I think that a lot of gen Z is
just exhausted and there's a reason why
I think so many genders say you know I
don't want to have families I don't want
to have kids and I think having children
is like the most hopeful thing you feel
like every generation says that though
crazy I talk to people and they're like
I do not want to have kids that's a deal
breaker stuff like that yeah I'm just
completely
it's better than being a father I don't
know but I really don't know I'm just
saying I think every generation says the
same thing to see what people say yeah
because imagine like going through World
War II and thinking like oh I don't want
to bring up a kid in this environment or
that's true I also will say I think it's
a part of the culture like people like
the rebellious nature of oh I'm not
going to have kids like that I'm a lone
wolf I want to be by myself that's also
because life can be pretty good if you
just default to like going on your phone
and like yeah and not having to numb in
the mind I think there's also less
societal societal pressure now to have
kids yeah you don't need to have it yeah
I think it's even in the opposite side I
think it's like I remember having
conversations with my friends in high
school who and I would say like I want
to have kids and they'd be like
throw it all away for a child like that
and I was like we're 15. and you're like
you're like I you're so angry about this
already it was and you know like even at
that young age they were so anti yet
it's also kind of cool to like say that
you don't want to have kids yeah you
want to be a lone wolf I see a lot of
people doing that as well yeah yeah well
I think there's a benefit in Waiting
that's what that's my belief yeah I mean
you should probably wait for you know
while you're ready but at the same time
for a lot of people they can have a baby
at a younger age and then they're kind
of forced to take in the parental role
and then mature I don't think that
should be done out of a pressure to like
but I feel like for a lot of women there
is that pressure where it's like you
know your mid-20s like when are you
gonna start having kids and I feel like
that shouldn't be still biological
you could also be 30 and have just as
successful I mean my mom did for me I
think it was 42. but as somebody who
literally wants like five or six
children I'm like
really obviously like not right now but
I do think about that of like I don't
think I want to be having a kid at 42.
and so I'm like it's kind of a tough
thing because you think you want to have
it at like you know 24 25 26 yeah
because you want to be young while your
kids are like growing up you play catch
with them and stuff like that your
shoulders don't hurt but at the same
time you want to be able to enjoy your
20s so I don't know it's tough situation
I think though when you have a kid at
least what I'm hoping for who knows if
it's actually like this is that just
everything in your life becomes so much
better everything and my last part
already very very good but as you have a
kid
but having your 20s and having that
freedom to pursue anything like you know
you moving here would have not have been
probably as doable if you had a newborn
and it's like that's something you don't
have to consider I mean I mean your mom
did move you around quite a bit when you
were young I was gonna say I also been
in a different situation where in a way
obviously it's not the same thing as
like the freedom in your 20s but I feel
like I've experienced a lot in my 21
years where it's like I've literally
moved all over the country I've traveled
International nationally I've had
multiple careers at this point it's like
all right cool I feel very stable in the
job that I have now and so it's kind of
weird I had this conversation with a
couple of friends of you know of mine
who are still kind of in this like flux
of like I don't know where I want to
live permanently or whatever and I was
like you know what I'm not really in a
position where if like I got pregnant I
wouldn't be like oh my God like what's
going on it's like oh I'm actually like
very stable and that's terrifying that's
actually scarier to me because I you
know was thinking like oh you know
farther down the line it was like oh
like I'm an adult now that's very very
weird to be like very comfortable with
that
um but no but I do I definitely think
for women like obviously it is you know
societal but for me at least it is
biological because it's I had you know
my brothers were 12 and 14 years older
than me my mom had me when she was 42.
they had a totally different
relationship with my grandparents than I
did because my grandparents were young
super fun I barely saw my grandparents
growing up because they were older they
were moving into assisted living they
didn't want to deal with like a you know
my one cousin that's closer to my age
and we like barely saw grandparents
because of that totally different my
brothers traveled with them did all of
this stuff and I remember Grant being
like I don't want that like I don't want
my parents to be tired I don't want my
you know grandparents to be I don't want
my kids to have that experience but it
all goes back yeah my mom was 38 when
she had me okay so for me that just
seems kind of normal yeah and it seems
like at least from my perspective you
pursue everything that you want to do
yeah you know on your own have that
freedom go and travel the world like
have those experiences and then once
you've done those then it makes sense I
think do you think you would still like
travel the world and do that kind of
thing with kids probably not um
I'm very set like I'm ready to set up
yeah well even for me traveling it's
just like it's not something I
necessarily lose that's crazy that to me
is
like being home okay comfortable I do
agree with that I don't like menial
traveling I don't like just hopping like
if I'm just like popping over to do like
a work thing oh my God it's exhausting I
don't I mean it's that's his favorite
kind of traveling work travel well I
mean it is paid for it so that's nice
but these days where it feels like
travel is so screwed up post covid in my
opinion where I feel every time I travel
like something goes wrong and I was in
the midst of like the Southwest chaos
over Christmas and I was like I cannot
do this anymore however like
international travel still excites me
and I've always said that I would love
to like spend a year abroad with my
future kids and like teach them another
language and do something like that but
I also think because I was homeschooled
and because I had so much flexibility I
think of like having kids just like oh
my God there's always activities like
this is so so cool see for me I want to
do van life with Macy and just travel
the United States in a van I'd love to
take the iced coffee hour on the road
like at some point get it get an RV I
wouldn't be opposed to it here's the
thing I'm a very open-minded guy like
anyone can pitch me anything in there
yeah sure why not let's see what happens
so I would I would be down to that test
it out for a year that's the one I could
have the bunk yeah but it's it's crazy
though but even like having a dog makes
things difficult because you can't
necessarily take the dog everywhere you
go having a cat easier but having a reef
aquarium is probably the most limiting
thing for me I can't believe here's
something that he wanted it so badly
this week uh 350 gallons it's really
it's really it's huge yeah yeah but it's
so delicate it's like someone's got to
be there to like fill up the water for
the reservoir like if you have like a
caretaker so I mean obviously there are
a couple people in Vegas that can do it
yeah they they know the ins and the outs
but still like if I'm there I test the
waters I make sure like if something
fell over it like yeah I keep it
pristine so leaving that for more than a
week at a time is difficult so that's
something so then thinking about kids
obviously I can't I can't do that van
life yeah Andrew are you taking the reef
aquarium with you no I wish I could
put it in the van custom built van I
heard this analogy and I loved it
because I always grew up planning on
having at least two kids and I was like
okay maybe two maybe three and then I
heard from somebody they're like I want
to have a bunch of kids and I was like
why would you want to have a bunch of
kids he's like man 10 11 12. yeah I'm
like why do you want somebody he's like
this again you want to say yeah meet
Kevin said it he's another Finance
YouTuber okay and he was like and I was
like why do you want to have so many
kids he's like think about it this way
man they're your best friends why would
you not want more best friends yeah and
I was like well that makes sense as long
as you can find your best friend I have
so many I have too many friends because
you're bonded by something like it's
kind of like a marriage it's like a
marriage right where you're you're
existing with somebody and you're living
with them and you're happy and
everything but as soon as you sign that
contract it's another level that you
have to break through if you want to
leave so you have to make it work
societal thing where so many people
think that marriage is like
is so much easier to throw away or it
doesn't mean as much and you know
they're like oh I can get married I'll
just get divorced if it doesn't work
like whatever oh no and it's like people
can make it work that's the thing and
they don't think that they do I think
people are way more compatible in
general what about instances of cheating
do you want to be with somebody who's
cheating
there's got to be a line there where
it's like there absolutely does but yeah
but they don't want it to work out at
all the thing is you have to it has to
be two people that both want it of
course yeah and you can make it work out
regardless of certainly I think that's
about the ending of marriage and more
about like as you're entering into
marriage and I see a lot of my friends
and I see some of them that are you know
a little more trivial with it and then
some that are you know I mean they take
it so so seriously this is the end I'll
be all and even if you're you know
already living with each other or
something like that still they say like
things change and you know you could
become just like oh we're basically
roommates but you have to like actively
work and so that's something I see with
at least like our generation of it being
like oh you know it doesn't work and it
doesn't you know we can just break up
basically and get divorced I'm like
that's somebody who went through that
was like one of the worst you know as a
child and that sort of thing I'm that's
not easy it's not a quick fix like that
thing took five freaking years
it's exhausting
um but anyway that was just my side
about marriage too but I do I think it's
a good thing to be like I want to have
friends so I'm gonna have kids it's just
like that's it's not friends man you got
to do it for yourself best friend okay
have you ever had a best friend before
yes and what was that like fantastic I
have many best friends and you can have
more as long as you have kids I think
look you have kids and not only that but
I feel like you're also contributing to
the greater good especially that's how I
feel but then you're a good parent that
seems selfish
if you want a best friend no dude I
think if you can raise kids and you can
turn them into great citizens and and
they're productive they help out people
they help out they Advocate yeah but I
feel like it with no expectation like
you have to go in thinking I'm going to
do this Best Shot no you go and you have
to be so intentional about having
children like that's what I'm saying
expectations but that's what I'm saying
but you can't go in with like they're
gonna love me and they're gonna do this
and do that I feel like well I think
they're kind of love right yeah I think
I love me they're gonna love Jack I was
gonna say I think that you know as
somebody who like with my brother and
that sort of thing I've watched his
relationship with my parents be so
fractured over the years of you know
with his you know drug abuse and like
that sort of thing I've also watched you
know with my father you know the way
that you know our relationship was you
know totally destroyed at some point
um and my mom and I have also gone
through periods you know where we're
closer we're not closer but especially
with her even in dealing with my brother
like I feel like I you know I watch her
as a parent and no matter what happens
like that love is unwavering and her
desire to
Force you it's like you look at parents
and your job is to like get the kid to
leave the nest basically to create you
know this productive fulfilled
independent go out and do good things
and that is like constantly her goal
that's the reason why she was
encouraging me to you know Take This Job
do this thing move across the country do
all of this with my brother it was not
just like oh honey I just want you it
was like I want you to be able to get
better so that you can go out in the
world and continue doing good things and
living your life and being fulfilled
like her job is not to keep you it is to
bolster and continue working and even
with like there were times where my
brother like hated my Mom hated the
things that she was trying to get him to
do I don't want to take these meds I
can't believe you're kicking me out of
the house like all of this stuff
unwavering
and even now it's like he permanently
lives in a psychiatric facility he's no
longer in like a necess or whatever like
he is non-verbal he will be there
permanently
um even like fully on meds like it went
so far and he was like totally sober was
not abusing drugs was Med compliant
living with me in Idaho for a year and
it just snapped one day and so he
permanently lives there and even still
like she still holds that hope like she
would still drop anything and do
everything even though he has like in
many ways totally blown up some of the
stuff that she offered and it's so that
is the coolest thing to me to be able to
like from her perspective of like you
get to experience a love like literally
nothing else and also it's it's
literally your job to mold
these humans to like send them out into
the world to hopefully be good people
and also like I said earlier it's sort
of like for the greater good but also I
think that having kids is hopeful and
saying like I do think that there is
like a world to be left for you like I
am going to do everything in my power to
make sure that the world that I leave
behind for you like my legacy or
whatever is you know something that's
good for you and I do believe that you
can change things and you can continue
or continue making change it's
incredibly helpful and that's when I
look at our generation who's like no the
world's doomed I don't want to have kids
because of that it's like oh my God like
no wonder Genesis is that the general
consensus though because I feel like
again we're just getting the Extremes in
either it's a pretty popular opinion
yeah yeah absolutely that's the reason
yeah this is a serious conversation to
have if you're dating at the stage
absolutely yes I just think it's you
know people are having kids later
because there's more opportunity out
there no way Millennials but for Gen Z
it's like super common yeah really oh
dude but then again it's crazy any one
of conversations I'll have and they'll
be like like it comes up and they say I
don't want to have kids immediately it
just yeah ends it ends it but don't you
think that's also can be an opinion that
changes over time it could be but why
would I risk it yeah that's a pretty
hefty
bodies and you're just saying you want
to have kids oh no I'm you know and
they're 19. I feel like that's a lot
more common my buddies I want to have
kids ask them 10 years from now the same
people might know how many who said no
will have kids just change I don't
really keep in touch with the people
that's it really do you just like just
audio all my friends are I like to think
that they're reflections of me in some
capacity and yeah they all want to have
kids in fact one of them you got married
already he's probably gonna have a kid
soon yeah same age so I mean like on the
flip side like my brother the oldest
brother thought about you know wanted
kids and then never you know really met
anybody that he wanted to have kids with
and so he's just kind of been like
resigned himself to not having kids
um so I mean I think it can change on
the opposite end but I think as somebody
who like you know dates intentionally
and like looks for a potential partner
and that sort of thing it's like if
you're even wavering on that right now
like now
yeah it's even like I think it's like a
value thing like from the get-go it's
like I'm so hopeful I'm so excited about
if you are not like that on board with
it of like wanting this kind of life and
it's like I know that I will probably
want to homeschool my kids for at least
part of my life which means or part of
their life
um which means that I you know will have
to you know he or I will have to make a
certain amount of money in order to you
know give that opportunity or if I want
to you know travel and live like a year
abroad with them or whatever like that's
kind of those are the kinds of things
that I bring up
um because it's yeah I think I brought
that up in the second date with Macy see
that's good yeah she she asked if I
wanted kids I said one day not right now
I want to want to do van life and do the
ice coffee hour but uh I was very
adamant about one and she's two so I'll
have that I'd be okay with two that's
good but I grew up really as like an
only child so for me I loved just having
like all the attention I get everything
yeah I don't know I think I think
there's a great relationship between
siblings I have an older brother and we
grew up together two and a half years
apart and the things that I learned from
his mistakes I didn't necessarily have
to learn them myself because I could see
him acting out of line my parents were
like oh you better not do that and I'm
like oh my God like hiding behind the
corner like okay I'm never gonna make
this mistake my brother made and at the
same time I can go out and experience
things my own way and the way that they
parent me the way that they parented me
it's completely different than the way
that they parented him and I think that
like the first go around you're like
okay I'm kind of figuring it out
learning as we go second time not saying
oh definitely nothing else parents are
better than my brother but I'll just say
like it was what I think that I was it
was for sure oh they were how were they
on you compared to your older siblings
well also because like I said my
brother's death I think changed a lot
for my mom but my oldest brother once
said and I think he'll still say this is
he had more freedom at military school
he wanted to go into the military for
his entire life he went to the Marines
private high school and then he went to
the Air Force Academy and he served for
a while still works for the Air Force he
had more freedom at military school than
he did at my mom with my mom I mean she
was very very very strict and he
respects it now but at the time you know
as a 15 year old boy hated it and I
watched their mistakes as well but I
think my mom relaxed a lot she was also
you know I think I got her at a point in
her marriage when she was a lot more
confident and knew that things were
wrong my dad was very you know has dealt
with very very severe mental health
issues and those are kinds of things
like she stuck with him for so long
through it and just got to a point where
it's like
was not good at all
um and so they divorced but I got to see
her you know at one story I don't think
I've ever told before is my brother
David a week before he died my dad had
this like major blow up blind rage and I
don't remember even what it was about he
threw something that was awful my
brother came into my mom's room crying
and was like why are you so married to
this man like why do you allow him to
treat us like this
um like I understand that he's ill I
understand that things are wrong but
this is not healthy this isn't wrong
you're not happy we're not happy and he
died a week later and I think I mean she
was like yeah ripped apart and I mean I
was five at the time yeah and so my then
childhood was totally changed and that
was like a snap for her of like I cannot
raise this child the same way and I
think constantly you know with my
brothers
she was battling between prioritizing
you know her first husband you know was
also I would say had a lot of demons but
he got brain cancer when my the middle
brothers were one and then he passed
away so my mom was dealing with like a
terminally ill husband and three boys
and then was a single mom uh and then
quickly got remarried to my dad who she
knew in college and then realized that
that was not what she had expected
either and so it was constantly for
their young adult life going back and
forth between like I have to care for
the husband I have to care for you I
have to like go back and forth back and
forth and I don't think I think she was
so wound up and so stressed and my
oldest brother now totally understands
that but it we were raised so
differently because but obviously like
our values are the same it was still the
same mother but the way that she you
know reprimanded us the way that she you
know gave us opportunities I think was
very very different it's interesting to
watch that but I also
in ways I felt like an only child
because my brothers were 12 and 14 years
older than me but I still had that
brother connection like when things were
really bad with my dad my oldest brother
who's 14 years older than me became like
that Father Figure in a lot of ways and
it's been like the support system that I
have I mean could not repay him for of
like he would be in Florida he would
answer the phone at 4am and I would be
like sobbing having some kind of panic
attack over something and he would just
sit there fly me out to him offered you
know you can live with me would get in
the middle of my middle brother and I
when my brother was having like
psychotic breaks and that kind of thing
I mean truly like stepped the hell up
and because of that I want to have like
a lot I want to give them that but also
hopefully closer in age
um but I just you know that's a kind of
relationship that I don't have anywhere
else so I think it's very very
empowering and empowering that's the
three word it's just really really
meaningful sure yeah is your older
brother still in Seattle uh no so he
never moved up there so oh that was the
part of the story that I ever finished
but I moved to Boise my mom was thinking
that she was going to be so close to all
of us and then I moved here my brother
stayed in Florida so now my mom was just
in Idaho
she was like why did I stay here I could
have gone you know back to the South but
yes my brother's in Florida okay I was
gonna say that would have been a wicked
coincidence because my brother's in
Seattle nice yeah now he's in
he's in Florida doing Air Force stuff
here's an interesting topic what do you
think about legalizing drug use
or decriminalize it
um
it's a really really hard subject
because I have this like personal
emotional
like tie to it and so my gut reaction is
like I don't want anybody doing that I
don't want any family to have to go
through what we did but I also kind of
look at it philosophically it's like
it's not my job to tell you what to put
in your body we already know that you
know drinking is a toxin and that's
legal and people you know drive drunk
and that happens and so you know drugs
are not healthy for us and you know most
senses
um it shouldn't be my job to tell you to
dictate what you put in your body
um but I also think that so many drugs
are just not studied well enough we just
don't really know the long-term impacts
especially on young people so I don't
really know if I have a firm answer
um for hard drugs I you know I'm not in
favor of it I think it's just there's
too much that's unknown I think it's
incredibly dangerous for people and
purely because of the an idol and maybe
that's you know
philosophically inconsistent I try to
stay really consistent but I think I can
be clouded by the fact that I have seen
with my brother and with the people that
he was on the street and I mean it
literally it can destroy you yeah and
you and you have we have no idea
yeah see part of me feels like if a lot
of these were legalized or at least
decriminalized to a certain extent that
you wouldn't have drugs laced with
fentanyl and all these other randoms
that could probably do more damage than
if that person went like hey here's a
trusted Source I'm gonna do it anyway
yeah uh at least I could go through this
Avenue we could regulate it to a certain
extent we could tax it and I think that
was my
we kind of where I started with all of
this and I thought that and then one
thing that kind of threw me for a loop
is looking at California after they
legalized weed is that now it is so
heavily regulated and taxed that
illegal you know marijuana growth and
selling is popped back up against it so
expensive and the labor laws are
terrible people are dying like they're
real it's like but my thought is on that
is that they only issued so many
licenses yeah and so it was like this
Lottery system and whoever didn't get a
license like well I'm just gonna do it
anyway yeah and I think it was a
terrible system to begin with and uh
seeing actually how they steal water now
from the state and they do them
illegally and they take water away from
fighting fires yeah nuts to me yeah but
that shows me that there there's a huge
market for it and they may as well
embrace it people are going to pull out
more people you know allow make it
easier for people who want to get into
that to do it properly and I think that
that's where it goes back to culture
where it's you know if we talk to young
people who think that you know drugs are
harmless and that sort of thing it's
like that's objectively a lie
um and maybe in some cases you know it's
fine but I do think if we are able to
have the tough conversations of saying
you know this is not like a
easy fix all you can't take this to cope
and fix everything you know there are
drawbacks to it just like with drinking
all of that I think you know at least in
my generation I see that people have
just gotten in my opinion way too
comfortable with it
um and I think that is difficult for me
so I think that's why I would focus more
on changing the culture around it of you
know being more responsible if you're
going to be because either way when the
government gets involved it's going to
be screwy regardless there's never going
to be a perfect situation nobody's ever
going to be happy there's always going
to be fault the government's going to
attack something too much regulate it
not enough whatever
um and so the only thing that I can do
as a person in my situation is tell you
know my family story share my opinion
about it and maybe keep some kid from
doing something that's like totally
irresponsible I guess that's what I
think good Role Models especially online
are really important I liked actually we
met a while ago with the strad man and
he's like no alcohol no caffeine no
nothing I'm just like working I'm having
a great time you don't have to do this
either even Danny Duncan is very much
against everything and I think when he
is an audience of millions of people who
watch every single video that goes a
long way like I guarantee you some 14
year old kids expect kids to have these
role models in the same way that you
can't expect a family unit to provide
all the yeah the reasonable values
everyone is up to somebody though
yeah but just because they look up to
somebody doesn't mean that it's a good
Idol you could have a false idol you
know and I think that it's it's a tough
conundrum that I've always deliberated
in my head it's like okay when should
the government step in to take care of
people because in my opinion like I have
a I have a pretty anti-drug just like
philosophy in general but at the same
time like similarly to you it's like you
want people to be able to make the
choice that they want to make and yeah
so I feel like for for drug use
specifically I don't think drugs should
be legalized I think they're incredibly
dangerous not really I think they're
incredibly dangerous and I think
it is so hard for me because I like to
say philosophically consistent at the
same time I think that some people just
can't make the right decisions for
themselves and doing drugs
objective I won't say objectively I will
not say objectively but I think it is a
terrible terrible decision yeah people
are people have addictive personalities
and they'll make they'll make bad
decisions and it goes so go down a
rabbit hole and screw yourself over
everybody that cares about you too where
do you draw the line and what drug weed
let's let's start there with weed for
like I you know I have friends that have
you know battled with autoimmune
diseases and you know cancer and that
sort of thing if it is like medically
like for people going through chemo if
you are you know given like a medical
cannabis thing and it's gonna you know
help you through or you know chemo I've
seen that be beneficial for people it's
like okay I think that's different than
like recreational use
but I would say like that's probably
wrong so so you would say that's where
you draw the line so you both would draw
the line I would say medical marijuana
would be fine really yes I think
honestly even recreational marijuana I'm
like well here's that really I don't
think it's like super damaging but the
thing is it becomes a lifestyle and
that's the part where it becomes
damaging it's like if you want to do it
for a little Escape at the same time
it's like
I think it's like a weapon I think you
know what I mean it could be used like
really yeah okay for my perspective
they're happy they don't fight each
other they're not like really getting in
trouble I see I see it largely as
something harmless and you know you
could argue maybe it's a gateway to
other things I don't know I would say
like medically I don't see it as
harmless with what is coming out about
how it changes your brain chemistry with
heart stuff
um smoking weed can be detrimental for
people who have like that's one of the
reasons why I never was going to do it
because my family has this history of
you know Cardiac Arrest there are links
there especially with young people
um and if you are smoking pot before
your brain is fully developed it's like
we just don't have those studies because
drugs have not been legalized they
really have not been studied and we have
not had you know the generational period
you know to see what happens to the kids
that have spent their entire you know
teen years College year smoking pot what
happens to them in 50 years we just
don't know and that's like a risk that
I'm not willing to take well don't we
don't we know what happens 50 years
later I feel like a lot of a lot of
adults
but again I think that the drugs now are
so different
it's dangerous because I like to compare
it to a weapon it's like you can use it
in a good way to defend yourself you can
use it as an escape sometimes if you
want to like lay low and whatnot but at
the same time you can use it to do
serious harm to yourself and people
around you but at the same time the
difference between obviously like a
weapon and weed is one is altering your
psychology and so that's going to impair
your yeah I say this by the way
someone's never done drugs oh nothing
I've smoked weed twice okay two or three
times I think in my entire life because
I was curious as like 16 years old yeah
that was it yeah never anything else but
I feel like alcohol is way more home
okay so I was gonna bring that up so I
have a really good friend of mine who is
probably the most like anti-drug person
I've ever met and like can like run
circles around people is so intelligent
but she also gets drunker than anybody
else in my life and so that's something
I brought up and I don't really drink a
lot and honestly I drank more before I
turned 21 and I've probably you know
could count on one hand the amount of
drinks I've had since October when I
turned 21 and I think I'm moving more
and more towards probably stopping
drinking and I did like dry January and
I loved it I think I've had one drink
since then
um and it's honestly I don't know if
you've noticed with our generation like
being sober is beginning like it's cool
very very popular yeah which is really
exciting to me but I'll bring up
drinking a lot and I'll you know look at
her and I'll say so what is the
difference and she doesn't really have
an answer
and it's like it is literally a toxin we
know now there was a new report from
oh God I was in Canada what was the the
organization it was like the Canadian
like Bureau of substance abuse or
something like that and it talks about
the links of alcohol to cancer and even
like one drink increases the likelihood
of Alzheimer's and cancer and so it's
like doesn't it depend on the drink
though because I've heard so many
studies on wine like red wine I think
can be a little different but still
alcohol in general and intoxication and
the impact that it has you know with
DUIs and people you know being
belligerent and killing people on the
road and that sort of thing
and it's like so you know we know we see
all these facts so how does it differ
and I think that's one point that I get
stuck on because obviously we've tried
Banning alcohol before that didn't work
so that's where I get so torn on it and
I just don't I just feel like people are
going to do it anyway yeah they're gonna
choose to do it something you can make
and it doesn't take many resources to
make something with alcohol it's the
same with weed true true about we I
guess I think there's a lot of drugs the
people could just restore to somebody in
L.A who was growing pot in their
apartment I mean yeah in their apartment
in their apartment oh yeah closets man
yeah yeah okay I've never grown one I'm
not really sure
I'm just saying I think people are going
to do it regardless okay that's yeah it
makes sense to regulate tax uh and offer
something pure where you know you're not
going to get like some something laced
in it that shouldn't be in there I do
Wonder though uh if if you change
something in the government right to to
criminalize all all drugs and whatnot to
a to a higher degree will that filter
down into a cultural change I feel like
for the most part I feel like no over
time over time if you give it enough
time okay so I think not to bring in
another like very polarizing subject but
in one instance this year where I feel
like I was even kind of proven wrong on
the cultures Downstream or no uh where I
was proven wrong on the politics is
Downstream from culture was the doc's
decision so the overturning of Roe v
Wade it was fascinating that in the like
two months
after that you know we saw all of these
girls going on like sex strikes and
saying I'm not gonna have sex because of
this and there was a whole Washington
Post article
about girls my age saying like
guess I'm not gonna be hooking up
anymore like guess casual sex isn't
gonna be for me because I can't do this
and you know guess I'm gonna have to be
more safe and it was all of these things
and it's like I think about as somebody
who is pro-life
um and that you know in the back of my
head and I'm somebody you know I don't
really value hookup culture I think it's
detrimental to especially Women's Health
and that sort of thing and they were
having you know they were making all
these decisions because of a law that
was put in place and then a lot of them
you know months on the line were like oh
this is so healthy like I need to be
anti you know hookup culture and that
sort of thing and I was like okay so I
guess in many cases it can also be
Downstream from politics when they were
forced to but it was such a it was a
weird
I don't know that was trippy for me
because I it was just interesting to
watch them inadvertently kind of fall
into like no this is actually healthy
yeah but in the drug case you have to
also think of enforcement and the cost
of that and the cost of putting people
in jail does someone really deserve to
be in jail because they have an
addiction or they have mental illness
they're coping with through drugs and
they have no violent defenses they're
minding their own business and they got
caught up because they bought something
on the street that they shouldn't have
been buying it's like is that the type
of person who deserves to be in jail
yeah so that's what I think
and maybe there's a difference you know
a different debate to be had between
like legalization and then
decriminalization and you know like what
should be criminalized I think more
mental health facilities I think would
be fantastic because I think a lot of
these yeah I don't know this it is but a
lot of it I think it boils down to
mental health yeah and I think we have a
culture
that on both sides of the political
aisle I don't think we know how to deal
with mental health and this is somebody
you know saying this to somebody who has
grown up in this environment which you
guys now know a lot about
um you know in addition to my brother
like I said my dad is dealt with a lot
um and that's been a huge part of my
life of you know in and out of therapy
you know on and off of meds and that
sort of thing
both sides of political aisle do not
know how to deal with it conservatives
have a reputation of believing that
mental health does not exist I'm friends
with a lot of people who believe that
who say it's all stupid none of it is
real and I'm like I literally have a
brother in a hospital right now that
cannot even function I know and
obviously a lot of that is now like
chemical in his brain but it's like that
is mental health I know that it's real
um I spent years in therapy I can tell
you that it's real but you know I
understand where you're coming from
because I think so many people
especially in my generation use it as a
crutch and will self-diagnose and so I'm
so depressed it's like no I think you're
dealing with a minor inconvenience I
think we've normalized it a little too
far and travelizing it and I think
there's also this kind of social
contagion of people adopting mental
health things and thinking that it's
kind of cool to be depressed it's very
cool to be like a tortured Soul these
days but then on the left you know they
claim to be you know very caring we're
going to fix this but then their
Solutions are you know Social Security
and you know telling people that they
you know affirming all of their problems
rather than saying like here are the
solution to make you get better it's
like we'll give you you know twelve
hundred dollars every two weeks and say
yes it's okay that you you know have
depression rather than saying no let's
let's fix this because it is a lifestyle
you know it is something that you can
take measures whether you're going on
meds or not to make things better in
your life even if it's literally just
getting off of your phone and sitting
out in the sun and eating a better diet
that does Wonder for you for a lot of
people yes and for some people it
doesn't you like my brother needs to be
on mitz must be on meds and for him it's
like what other I do think that there
need to be better Mental Health
Resources because for somebody like him
his only option right now is the state
hospital
there is no place there is one private
place in the country that I have
identified that if like my mom passes
away and he's in Idaho right now and I
need to like step in like as part of the
you know is taking care of things
there's one place that I can get him to
if I don't want him to be you know 11
hours away I think he's more than that
because he's a couple of hours away from
her one place it is in Tennessee that
does like intensive care and that's
private and it costs thousands of
dollars but that's something that I
think about in the back of my mind of
like okay I know that I will want to
take that on and I like agreed to take
care of his estate and that sort of
stuff there's one of them and obviously
I don't think that the Asylum system was
great and that's one thing that you know
Reagan got rid of
but and there were obviously they
mistreated a lot of people but there's
nothing like that anymore it's like what
happens to those people instead they
just end up on the street yeah they end
up abusing drugs that's what I've seen
in Los Angeles I think a lot of the
people on the street they're mentally
ill yes and they don't have any
resources or places to turn it's like
what are they going to do they're on the
streets it's either they get picked up
by police go to jail get released right
afterwards that just that that doesn't
solve anything no and in my opinion just
giving them cash every week also does
nothing because you can get more money
if you're crazier I remember my brother
was with like this community of homeless
guys and one of them
um who actually passed away a year ago
and we planned this funeral he became a
really good friend for my brother I mean
this man was like 50 years old he lived
on the street for most of his life was
so tortured knew that he was dying and
like took care of my brother in a lot of
ways and if Reed was in trouble like he
would call me and be like and he would
be high out of his mind and still be
like reads in trouble reads passed out
like you need to come get him and that's
what I mean was incredible
um but he would fake seeing like aliens
and have visions in order to get more
money because the crazier you are you
get more money
and so a lot of that is like put on
because then who's that how did they do
that how do they judge like it's like a
severe like go in front of a
psychologist or a psychiatrist or it's
like what is money what does money help
with in that scenario is that because
like you're that much less likely to
work yep that's what it is yeah but then
they don't actually like my brother
never tried to get a job the people that
he was around never tried to get a job
one of them got into a halfway house you
have to apply for those sure like the
living facility that my brother was in
in La he had to apply to get in and he
had to pay like 50 a month or something
like that so he used his social security
for that uh you would get food stamps
but food stamps were separate then the
Social Security cash that you were
literally just given
um and so there wasn't an incentive for
him to do that and when you are that
mentally gone like all he cared about
was getting drugs so if he was getting
1200 every two weeks to go just smoke
pot and like trip on acid and that sort
of thing like
he was going to do that and so I think
you know as somebody who is not really
in favor of a lot of government
intervention but I still think you know
we do have these resources I think that
you're just allocating the wrong
resources to these people and you think
the money is going to fix it then you're
going to Pat yourself on the back like
the LA you know government like this is
so great we're fixing all this it's like
look at the people on your streets
they're literally suffering and they
just die there and there's there's no
other resources and just giving away
taxpayer dollars does something and
there's so many incredible organizations
and non-profits and churches that step
in and try to help but there's only so
much that they can do
um but then on the conservative side I
think that there is such a missed
opportunity on the right because we talk
about
personal responsibility and
accountability and you need to be a
productive member of society and take
care of your health like there are all
these studies that you know
conservatives are happier than liberals
you know conservatives take care of
themselves more
um because they care about personal
responsibility they don't want to rely
on anybody else that is an opportunity
to reach those people and say like you
are worth more like we can help you
rather than like affirming this literal
illness it should not be hey you don't
have a problem you're being stupid it
should be okay what are the necessary
steps in order to get you out of this
because you deserve more because you
have more potential right and it's like
that is such a good weather you care
about politics or not it's like that is
what we should be giving these people
it's not just throwing them cash being
like Oh so sorry
so how do you make a change on that I
have no idea it may be cultural I again
I go back to like changing the
conversation about it I'm very very open
about talking with my family's mental
health issues which I think is something
that is very
not really seen on the right I'm really
the only person that I know of that
talks about this stuff very very
publicly I spent years in therapy
um I would have like panic attacks
weekly when going through stuff with my
brother and when right after I got
emancipated my mom was back in Tennessee
dealing like finalizing her divorce I
would go I have to like find my brother
on the street and would like maybe see
him passed out or like he was tripping
on something like it was awful
um then I dealt with that for years I
had therapy
before a lot of that started I did for
therapy with my brother to kind of deal
with my his twins death and we did
therapy together because he only agreed
to do it if I would do it with him and
then I had therapy to deal with that
brother wow so I've been in it a lot
um and it's like I know that it's real I
know people deal with it I know that our
generation is the most mentally ill
generation in history so it's like why
there's so many reasons um I think
social media has a lot to do with it
technology yeah I think that's a huge
important thing like present in the real
world yeah I would say
um I think that the fear porn in the
world around us where everything you
know you know the media is designed to
get clicks like you said the world is
ending you know everybody's worried
about you know gun violence people are
worried about you know the future of
this country democracy ending climate is
actually it is the number one stressor
for Our Generation like there is climate
anxiety climate depression is now like
an actual diagnosis that you can have
and our media like feeds into that and
so I think that's a big part of it and
it's interesting that a lot of these the
stressors for a generation is external
rather than like
I always thought of Mines like it came
from my family it was very internal but
all of this is like all the external
stuff I think it's just because we have
more access to everything and it's
immediate yeah and I still think it's
the extremes like I keep going back to
tick tock I'm just showing like the
worst of the worst of the world on
either end of the spectrum just to get
like clicks comments I think it was on
Facebook the angrier someone gets the
more likely that is to be at the top of
the page and it was the anger that they
went after not fear or sadness it was
like how angry is this going to make
them to stay on here and write a comment
right that's right we can have that
conversation too about like how many
people are actually diagnosed with
things because you know we look at the
stats for Gen Z and it's like our
numbers are off the charts but some of
those are you know self-diagnosed
self-proclaimed whatever so I think
that's another conversation but also
like you said we're being fed this very
extreme content so what is the impact
that that is having on the viewers yeah
so then if it's constantly angry if
everybody around you was constantly
depressed they're all anxious
everybody's having this like identity
crisis const recently it's like that
becomes then the norm and whether you
have that extreme or not I just see
people kind of becoming complacent and
believing that that's just the norm yeah
well speaking of extremes what do you
think of Andrew Tate
foreign
you know
I think that he's done good I watch his
clips and I think that he's done a lot
for you know some young men I think it's
I think he's an interesting figure
um I think he started a lot of really
important conversations do I think that
he is like a masculine role model no I
don't
I think partially because I just don't
love that lifestyle I'm like I look at a
man and I don't qualify his masculinity
because of how rich he is or how fast of
a car he has or how many like high you
know s-tier women he's able to get even
if it's a Bugatti though well yeah do
not care like I would rather you drive a
truck or some kind of bronco and be a
normal guy and have really great values
and like I don't care how many cigars
you smoke and so I think that kind of
turns me off a bit maybe that's very
superficial but I'm like I just don't
you're not appealing to me but I
understand that guys like that
um and I understand that it's like in
like cool for them and that sort of
thing and maybe you can you know I don't
know what you think about him but I know
I have guy friends who are like oh he's
so cool like he's making me feel like
empowered me a shocked that people can't
see like I see in terms of politics I
see both sides equally and I'm like I
love these things about this yeah I love
these things about this and we could
like bring them together but I don't
identify necessarily with one or the
other I just kind of pick and choose
bits and pieces but I do the same thing
with people it's like I might disagree
with some things they say but I'm like
that one thing I kind of like that yeah
and I'll pick and choose from that I
think people have the ability to do that
though because it seems like now it's
it's less it's it's less about saying I
like this one thing about this person
and I agree with like taking
accountability I think people are more
close-minded when they get a little bit
younger though so like I think like our
generation gen Z is like they like you
either hate them or you love them but
for an older generation I feel like it's
it's it's much different than normal
like I well there am I Elder you're a
millennial right a millennial you are
older there you go true
um like I got flamed actually I wasn't
terrible but I definitely did see some
pushback in my comments because I was
talking about Jeffree Star and he you
know was talking about you know gender
binary and that kind of thing and he
came out and he was saying like the they
them stuff it just doesn't make sense
um and he's also spoken out against you
know gender transitions for children
saying they're not ready for that that
sort of thing and so I made a video and
I said you know obviously this YouTuber
has a lot of controversy controversy
he's done a lot of stuff people hate him
for many reasons but this is something
that we can commend at least so my
audience can commend he sang protect
children there we go and people were
like no but he's done all this all like
other stuff and I don't like him I'm not
like raw Raj every Star I love all your
videos but I'm like hey that was a that
was a good thing I think some you know
conservatives also think that that means
like you're bending the knee you're
compromising your values I'm like no I'm
not becoming a fan I'm just
acknowledging when somebody does
something that you know might be
beneficial for a listener might open up
their eyes to something new and I think
it's the same thing with Andrew Tate
like you're saying his lessons and his
messages of you know taking
accountability as a young man and
speaking young men and saying I know
it's hard for you right now I know that
you know modern feminism you know tells
you you need to be effeminate and like
all of this stuff like I know it's tough
but here are some of the things that you
could do do I like the way he speaks
about women no I don't I think it's very
weird
and obviously you know there's a lot of
back and forth about what he was doing
in Eastern Europe or whatever I don't
love the way that he's spoken about that
like I remember he said you know I think
it was about sex trafficking or no it
was like you know he doesn't condone
rape but you know in some countries it's
technically legal so and I was like well
like there's still a moral wrong there
there's still a moral wrong I think that
kind of goes back to like even if
something's legal or whatever else still
yeah I would believe that it is wrong
um so I obviously don't support those
things but I think he's had viral
moments and I think he has started
important conversations online maybe
that's how I would kind of frame it yeah
I'd agree with that I think he's a
disrupter and I think disruptors are
extremely needed because it's super easy
to do that's a good way to put it yeah
yeah it's kind of like he gained a lot
more power than I feel like you should
probably give to a disrupter just in
general because usually disruptors are
more extreme and you don't want someone
super extreme to be like exactly but
there's more gravitational pull with
people that are extreme like him so it
makes sense what I noticed with Andrew
Tate people that like are around me that
are like big Andrew tape Fanboys is the
fact that he kind of gave that whole
victimhood mentality to dudes which a
lot of people don't really see but
that's what I saw because he was like
you know it's hard to be a dude dudes
are depressed at rates that have never
been seen before and stuff like that and
guys are like oh my God and everybody
yeah
everybody wants to be a victim but a lot
of people it's easy to be a victim
because then you have an excuse so
people were like okay yeah this sounds
good and then he's like but there's
light at the end of the tunnel yeah and
people are like oh wow that's cool and
everybody every dude wants to be a
Heroes of the fear but I think he he
offers some like Solutions I think he
acknowledges like ah things are tough
and I think you brought up an important
point because
I kind of struggle with you know talking
to you know my audience of like young
men and young women and saying like you
have it really bad and this like Society
is so screwed up but I try to make it
pretty even
talking about like the boy crisis
because I also think that there is a
huge like young woman crisis like
there's a reason why the majority of
young people transitioning right now are
girls like there's a reason why like I
think girls committing suicide at a
young age is now above I mean it's like
girls have so many issues as like a
young girl I knew what it was like I
understand going through puberty and
literally feeling like you don't belong
in your body and what's going on in all
of this stuff
um but I think only telling people that
you are a victim and the people hate you
is not the best and so I do think with
things like Andrew Taylor it's like I
wish that he had offered more solutions
in a way of like all it was was like get
rich buying my program and also work out
which is great yeah get a six-pack that
was very interesting advice but but it's
like I think but at the end I agree I
agree let's go to the gym yeah go to the
gym and bring value yeah because I'd
also get rich and get like a harem of
women which I feel like it's just like
okay yeah it's like okay we can take
what we want the ideas that we went by
making money but by making money you're
adding value in some way uh it can
you're being a productive member of
society it could be it could bring a lot
of purpose depending on what you're
doing if you're adding value to somebody
else
could be setting goals I don't think
money brings purpose but I'm saying if
you're doing something of value or
making money oh okay yeah yeah sure yeah
yeah not the money itself but like to
bring value you have to be doing
something to society you have to be
doing something of value hopefully yeah
to do that no I think that there are
really good takeaways and really poor
takeaways for okay absolutely yeah but I
think the best way that you said it was
a disrupter and I agree we need more of
those because I think people get so
caught up in this very polarized group
think I think if one person on you know
other sides pops through it's like I
disagree with this and it causes like
mess whatever it starts conversations
whether or not that changes people's
minds I think polarizing figures like
Joe Rogan is a great example and he's
somebody that's kind of
wrote it really well I think
um of like he's unafraid to say things
that are super controversial and have
people on that are you know
controversial
and opening up those conversations and
he'll say something every once in a
while people are like oh my God but you
like him so much and I always gained
this audience and it's like okay you
respect it but I think having those
people pop up is so important for this
culture where everybody is so terrified
to say something that is out of line
it's like that isn't what it should be
how do you balance that though between
maybe because you have a very uh big
audience at this point a lot of people
listen to what you have to say how do
you balance your own thoughts and and
think you know maybe I have some biases
here yep how do I present both sides
because my whole uh thinking with with
my channel is generally presenting both
sides and letting people come to their
own decision be like here's for and
against you know I kind of somewhere in
the middle but I'll let you decide how
do you
um I think for the most part I will try
to explain my bias and so like for
example if we're talking about drugs I
will explain my family's history with
that if I'm talking about something like
as a young woman or I have a personal
experience I will explain that and I try
to be as personal as possible and it
obviously like I walk a fine line
because you know I am a public figure
now and so people you know get a lot of
insight into my life you kind of have to
draw that line of like how far am I
willing to take it and I think the best
way I've described it is like
there's a point where like online Brett
ends in like real life Brett kind of
continues and I you know decide when I'm
keeping private but for the most part I
try to be totally transparent so that
people know exactly where my biases come
from sure because if you don't if you
don't know then it's just me as like
some Idol telling you what to think but
if you understand how I have come to the
conclusions that I have come to that is
the thing that I respect in listening to
the people you know that I listen to so
for instance when I'm listening to Ben
understanding his religion and his
values and his culture makes so much
sense and it's like oh I I relate to you
I understand obviously I don't really
because I'm not a Jew but it's like I
can understand how you have come to this
conclusion
um and I think that creates more of a
human to human connection which is
always what I'm trying to achieve it's
like appealing to emotion
um and then also I always try to leave
people with a more empowering message
and so maybe that makes me you know I'll
you know land on one side or the other
but I will usually try to land with a
thing that does you know make people
most empowered and makes them turn
against a victim mentality sure and so
if there's an opportunity to present
that it's less about politics and more
about you know as I've said before you
are deserving of more you can do more
and you are holding yourself back if you
are claiming that you are oppressed nine
times out of ten in this Society it is
because you are doing it yourself
whether that is like physically or your
mindset and that is something that I
don't think should be political that
sadly has become political anymore and
so if I can encourage my audience to
just push themselves even more then I
would do that but I think with the
biases part of it it's just explaining
my own and how often do you change your
opinions on something
because you're mentioning debates a lot
yeah at what point or maybe give us some
examples of sometimes where you've
debated and come away from it being like
you know what they have some great
points I agree I think drug legalization
has been one that I've like struggled
with because I came probably you know in
the last few years I think I've become
more Pro uh or I guess more anti-drug
legalization even though I had my own
you know family's history with it as I
just learned more about the impacts of
you know legalizing it what happened the
impact on other people outside of my own
bubble because I was just kind of
thinking of it in my family's bubble and
so I thought that's probably not the
best way to look at it
um and being around people who you know
have differing opinions and I've you
know tried to debate people who are you
know not pro-legalization and I just
kept falling short
um I was like okay so maybe that is a
sign
um especially when morally I kind of
lean that way but I think the biggest
one was I used to be pro-choice
um and I was in my part morally I knew
that was something I could never do that
was never something I would do I knew
that it was objectively wrong however I
always you know thought of it as their
two lives that are at stake here uh
we're talking about The Mother We were
talking about the baby and if I am
somebody who is anti-government
intervention I don't want the government
telling me what to do with my life my
body
why do I have any say over what you know
this woman is doing and I don't know her
life experience whatever right
um but then I'm just leaving this unborn
child with no or whatever so that was
very very complicated for me but as
somebody who at the time I was a lot
more libertarian and I still think that
I I probably lean a little bit more that
way than a lot of people that I'm around
I have very conservative values but I
think I can fluctuate on that when it
comes to how far I want to legislate
that
um but anyway then I got to UCLA and I
started to see the pro-choice people
that I was around were not really just
pro-choice they were pro-abortion and
that was kind of when like Miley Cyrus
did like the abortion cake and it was
like literally celebrating abortion but
do you think maybe that you saw the
extremes on that side and that maybe a
lot of people land somewhere else in the
middle but you guys could see them yes
um and there are you know the majority
of people
this country I believe
you know would you know support abortion
up to a certain point and they do
believe that there need to be
restrictions upon it so I know that
there are people there who like
understand that this cannot be you know
extreme but as I'm thinking about it on
a cultural level the fact that just in
the last few years people getting so Pro
abortion like they are so angry about
this issue that they just take it to the
extreme that they are like the media and
I think the media you know is a lot to
blame for this because they just Stoke
this fire over and over again and so I
put a lot of the blame on them but it is
you know creating this entire culture of
people that whether intentionally or
unintentionally are becoming so like
just angry and pro killing something and
it's like how did we get here from
saying I just want autonomy to now the
majority of the rhetoric that comes out
about this is pro-abortion it's like the
the Jessa Duggar story that just
happened a couple of weeks ago where she
had a miscarriage and you know the 10
media Outlets that covered it all said
that it was an abortion it was like it
wasn't you just saw this woman crying on
YouTube for 18 minutes about her
miscarriage I was a missed miscarriage
and she had to have a DNC to have the
fetus removed because she did not pass
the naturally and you're saying that
because she did that it's an abortion
was not they're like she's lying about
it it's like so you're using the story
twisting somebody's personal experience
for your agenda it's like that's why I
had a major problem with it sure
um then it doesn't seem genuine so I saw
a lot of that at school
um I saw you know my sorority sisters
who were on like abortion number two
because they weren't on birth control
and just saw it as kind of like a backup
plan like oh yeah you know it's fine
I'll just use it as birth control
um and then the kicker for me was
learning that my dad wanted me to be
aborted and that was like like my
parents marriage by the time that I was
conceived was already over my mom knew
that she wanted a divorce wow she stayed
because of me and we can argue whether
that was a good thing or not a good
thing and we talk about that a lot
um about what that would have changed in
my childhood and that sort of thing and
I'm you know happy with how things
turned out but how did you learn about
that like where did that seems like a
tough yes but I was calling my mom about
abortion and I was like I'm just so
conflicted right now because I was like
this is something I could never do I
like I know that I could not I know that
it's morally wrong that we were going
back and forth and my mom is incredible
at showing both sides of it and so she
would argue it you know kind of play
Devil's Advocate She would argue it from
you know the perspective of the mother
she would argue it from you you know
over protection of The Unborn try all of
this would go back and forth what makes
the most sense I mean she this is
something she's changed her opinion on a
lot because she used to speak for a
choice as well but I mean back and forth
back and forth hours of talking about
this of like I just don't it's such a
complicated issue that deserves so much
empathy and so much grace and I think
people on both sides of political aisle
just do not give it that there's some
people on the right as well who you know
villainize mothers who have had
abortions I'm like that's not freaking
productive either and there's so many
people who literally do not think that
they have another option it is our job
to show that there is another option and
to amplify you know the pregnancy
centers and you know the resources that
are available to you because they you
know outnumber abortion clinics they
actually like on paper they do and you
know you can have these resources
um and so anyway that's just a whole
aside but we would go back and forth
back and forth and I was like I just
don't know Marley and I was really torn
up about it
um and she was like I'm gonna you know
be very personal with you and she was
like when you know we found out that I
was pregnant
um Mike wanted you to be aborted and he
was like we knew our marriage was over
this wasn't obviously planned at all
um and he was like I want you to make an
appointment and go and she was like that
totally changed my mind because she said
I had not even considered that this
would impact me personally I was a
mother of three that would never be a
concern of mine and she said having like
a life inside of me and being told that
like I would end that she was like after
going through multiple pregnancies and
like in that moment feeling I knew that
that was never anything that I could do
I think then her perspective shift
shifted because for her it had always
been about the rights of the mother and
she was like like this is somebody that
you know is the most vulnerable person
in our society who literally has no
autonomy that is fully dependent on this
other person and I think that is where
her perspective shifted
um and for me making it very very
personal it was just like okay yes you
know
it did a lot yeah don't you think saying
that though would automatically push you
to one side like that you can't get more
personal than that I don't think so
because a lot of people
like I you know I
had an abortion and they still support
it uh I was watching a video at one
point and a girl was like yeah my
parents almost awarded me I wish that
they did it probably would have been
better for my mom and that kind of thing
so I know that there are people who have
different responses and maybe they are
already predisposed to that opinion
that's fair
um but as somebody who was already
predisposed to that pro-choice opinion
it was interesting that's just like
flipped but I wish you hadn't heard that
I don't think so no okay because I think
it gave me a lot more empathy for my
mother for what she was dealing with at
the time with my father
um it obviously created another fraction
with my dad's in my relationship that's
water under the bridge now and we've
talked about it and you know he would
never have you know suggested that now
and he was in came from a place of fear
and anger and you know that sort of
thing
um but I'm glad that I did because it
gave me a greater perspective about you
know the way I was raised the dynamic
I've had a lot of confusions you know
with the my relationship with my dad and
I just didn't understand a lot of stuff
and I think that you know as I got older
the transparency that my mom you know
gave me about my family and being able
to like I wasn't really shielded from a
lot and some people would say that that
was a bad thing but I think that it was
it forced me to grow up quickly but it
also like I knew what to expect in my
family I understand
why I am the way I am because of my
family like none of that was hidden from
me um so no I don't I'm not upset that I
learned that got it yeah
what do you think is the biggest threat
to humanity right now oh gosh ourselves
what about their mindset um I would say
people are so desperate to be I've said
it a lot today but they are so desperate
to be victims and I think that they are
like as a society we're holding
ourselves back whether that is you know
and I think a lot of the victimization
is fueled by a desperate need for
attention because victims get attention
you know what I think it's acceptance
because it's easier to be a victim and
other victims love to wallow and misery
what is it misery loves company so when
you're upset and you could gossip with
someone else and say this sucks and blah
blah blah and go back and forth you feed
on that and you feel like I'm not alone
and I have that feeling of just like
yeah exactly I feel like that's as you
begin to get more successful it becomes
harder and harder to find those
connections yeah exactly and I but I
will say I do think attention is part of
it because we've seen that like the
marginalized communities that say that
they're marginalized they get a lot of
attention it pays to be an activist it's
like that sort of thing and so I don't
think that is the case for everybody
because obviously not everybody ends up
making money in that but I think that
there are a few examples that glorify
people are like oh this is cool like I
will get the attention I will get this
community I will be affirmed I will be
accepted into this because I'm not alone
and I think that there's a lot of you
know very you know hurting people
um and I think that as a society we have
you know allowed that mentality to take
prevalence and so if I could leave you
know people with one message is that you
know
it being empowered is the most like
freeing thing that you can do for
yourself saying I don't care what other
people think is the most freeing thing
that you can do for yourself being
self-reliant there was literally no
better feeling like me walking out of
the street knowing that I can beat
somebody up because I did years of
self-defense that I like carry a gun
that I'm totally self-reliant I don't
depend on you know a family mommy and
daddy's not anything like that that I am
totally it's like the most empowering
thing in the world there's literally no
better feeling and it's like why would I
sacrifice that just to be like accepted
by a group of people that is also like
down in the dumps and not productive
enough yeah yeah so I would say I think
it's ourselves interesting and also
Elites in government toying with our
lives I would say I would say it's like
at the very base level of society
because only we push ourselves like
forward as a culture but I also do have
to admit you know there are people that
do not have our best interests at Hearts
because all they want to do is make more
money and be more corruption well that's
why I think it's important to teach
objective thinking I would love a common
sense class just like taught in school
like this is this is bad this is good
but make Common Sense choices yeah for
you yeah and just just pick like like we
were talking about earlier picking and
choosing like the bits and pieces that
you identify with I think is really
important I think that people Overlook
the importance of like logic classes and
ethics classes and I'm so grateful that
I took those in college the one of the
most important classes I ever took also
was political philosophy understanding
where my opinions come from on a
philosophical level was so important to
be having to Advocate like I remember
having to write a paper in support of
marks which is like the farthest thing
that I could have ever like done but
having to get into that mindset and
understanding like on a human level why
are they driven in this way what were
the benefits of this ideology and having
to learn all that seeing every single
slide especially if you have a really
good professor I did all of those
classes at Community College it was
exceptional but I did logic I did ethics
I did political philosophy and then I
did a couple of other like political
Theory classes they were incredible
because I had to do every single side
but I was also in a good situation where
you know they also had people like
nozick pop up who was like the father of
libertarianism we talked about Iran and
like her you know philosophy so I was
getting both sides and I had to advocate
for and against things that I like loved
and believed and things that I hated
that's the one class I wanted to take
was debate yeah because I feel like
that's such a useful thing to know yeah
and debating is a skill yes because even
if your idea might Trump somebody else
like if you can't communicate that to
another person like you know you're
gonna meet with Sean [__] he's an
incredible debater because he's so fast
what do you think is more important in
debate do you think it's the actual
stuff that's coming out of your mouth
like the words that the transl the
transcript or do you think it's the the
ability to use rhetoric
it's the ability to use rhetoric I would
say like my opinion isn't necessarily
like suede because I will always try to
I don't think that my opinion like
quickly changes in debate but I think
who you determine like wins I think most
people pick and choose who wins a debate
because of the rhetoric not because
interesting I think when you're writing
I think that's a different thing because
it's so much slower but when you are
back and forth and back and forth with
somebody it is the ability to be very
very Nimble with your diction
and there's a reason why it's like
literally a skill yeah and confidence I
feel like if you go in with confidence
and you don't take anything personally
and you remain objective
um that's what I think does it whoever
sounds more confident in their books I
think generally and it doesn't take any
BS right it doesn't give in and that's
why it's like
I might be a terrible debater because
I'm always somebody who's like oh yeah
tell me more like oh I like you let me
understand I always go in thinking that
I could be wrong yeah yeah I just think
like hey I'm open-minded to a lot of
things and I'm okay to change my opinion
if it's wrong yeah so like I'll hear the
other side and be like you know what
there's some good points in that like
yeah I'm open to it yeah so I'd be a
terrible debater yeah I want to hear
more about your anti-porn
stuff oh God all right all right here we
go
um I also think that porn is one of the
things that is destroying my generation
why is it so bad
um okay so for first of all with the
porn industry we know that like it is
fueled by criminal activity I mean the
sex trafficking industry is like
funneled through porn PornHub is dealing
with I mean at this rate 10 plus 15
lawsuits
um children being molested put on the
site it's just it is a breeding ground
for terrible behavior
um for women I think we are fed this lie
um well that you can as women I think we
are fed this lie that you can have this
super happy and productive and like
fulfilling life by just selling your
body
um it will not be that way you look at
the mental health of sex workers you
look at the mental health of you know
porn stars it's not good there's like
the one percent like on only fans who
makes you know they make millions of
dollars and they're great and that you
know will sustain them whenever they
stop doing this kind of work but for the
majority of them it is a terrible
terrible terrible industry I'm gonna
play Devil's Advocate yes and very much
doubles out okay okay
yeah Graham's laughing yeah uh okay so I
think a lot of people they fall into the
porn industry because it's just like Oh
you mean by happenstance I may as well
do this I can make a good Buck here 100
uh so I could see why that would
probably not work very well mentally for
people it's like falling into something
where like you said selling your body
but those that do intentionally move
into the industry uh and they know that
that's something that they enjoy don't
you think and that's I guess you did
allude to the one percent of people yeah
if it works for you then that's fine and
I I will never say to your face like you
are lying to yourself about it because
I'm sure that there's some people that
just like genuinely don't care and they
have a good experience with it but I
think on a whole I'm looking at like
the entire gender like women are not
you know and I maybe this goes back to
like coca-culture and that kind of thing
but when you look at men and women men
are biologically designed to go so the
seeds there's a reason why you do not
carry a child for nine months for women
it's like I need to find this one
specific partner I can only be pregnant
for nine months like I can only carry
basically you know I can only have one
pregnancy at once I have to protect
these eggs I only have you know a set
amount of eggs that I'm you know created
um and so we are very very protective
over that with men you are literally
designed to go repopulate the Earth
literally and so with women there's a
reason why like biologically hook up
culture and just living with a bunch of
people and leaning into that and I guess
you know porn is a little bit different
but still this like sex positive culture
for women I don't think it's healthy
because it's going against how I believe
we are literally biologically designed
um and I think for young men it is
allowing them to be complacent with just
living online and not having real
relationships like
the violence in marriages has like Sky
also I mean I'll finish that thought and
go into it um but I mean like violence
in relationships domestic abuse has like
skyrocketed with the normalization of
porn often in domestic abuse like often
in domestic abuse situations the man is
like addicted to porn or has a history
with it
um 52 of divorces in this country cite
porn as an issue which is just an insane
stat
um but it makes sense because if you're
unhappy and you're trying to find
fulfillment or pleasure somewhere else
you're going to go that way
um but I was reading this Reddit post
from this person they were arguing the
benefits uh and the drawbacks between
only fans and PornHub and they were
arguing that only fans was better and
one of the arguments for only fans being
better was because they were subscribing
to an individual girl and they could
create this like parasocial relationship
with her and it's like it feels better
because I'm not really objectifying her
we have a relationship we can chat and I
can feel better it's like then go out
into the real world and ask a girl on a
date like poor is allowing young men to
stay in front of their computers and not
strive for anything else like overuse of
porn over the masturbation it [__] with
your hormones like biologically it has
impacts mentally uh men who are porn
addicted uh who even just are not even
important addicted but watch copious
amounts of porn are mentally very very
unhealthy like it is not natural
um and it's just like
and then on top of it with the industry
being so dangerous it's like why is this
something that we have just become you
know so accustomed to and it's happened
really fast like my mom and I were
talking about it my producer
um Matt scheller whenever uh but my
former producer doesn't work here
anymore he was in his 40s we were
talking about like with he and my mom
where if you wanted to watch adult
content
40 years ago 30 years ago you had to go
to a theater and you had to watch you
know you know with a lot of people like
there was a reason why I'm forgetting um
who the actor was it was like arrested
for masturbating in a theater like in an
adult film or then later on with like
Blockbuster and that sort of thing you
had to go into like the adult section
and you were you know we're in public
renting it out and that sort of thing
but it has become more and more private
where now it is literally on your phones
you can do a quick Google search it is
so at people's fingertips that there is
now not really a stigma around it women
are almost like encouraged to go into it
in a lot of ways you look at you know
things online you see girls that you're
never making millions you know basically
objectifying themselves and you know
selling their bodies is almost appealing
with men it's become so commonplace you
know boys start seeing form but they're
like 13 years old I saw porn for the
first time when I was I think probably
14 or 15.
um it's just it's become so normalized
so quickly and that is like the most
shocking thing to me
um and I also think in a similar way as
we were talking about like the culture
around smoking weed I do think that
there's like a culture around young men
who just sit in their homes and they
just watch porn I do agree I think the
accessibility to porn is the real issue
porn itself I don't know if that's like
a huge issue of guys know exactly what
they're doing and they're very
intentional about it and the girls that
go into the business are very
intentional about going to the business
they feel Pride with what they do I feel
like there's probably no problem with
that uh well I would say there is a
problem with with sex trafficking for
sure yeah well yeah yeah I think now
PornHub don't they verify IDs you can
still get around that's still like I
mean Netflix is about to drop a whole
documentary I think next month literally
just about the sex trafficking I mean
trafficking objectively yeah of course
that's a bad part I'm just talking on
the theory of porn itself yeah but
something that's crazy to me is that
laws are just now being put in place
where you have to verify your age to get
on PornHub like before it was like you
could just put in any birthday and get
on and watch it states are just now
rolling out you need to verify like if I
was verifying my student discount on
Spotify putting in a student ID whatever
imagine a data breach like if we can't
trust Equifax yeah I'm just I'm just
saying yeah there's there's lists you
you don't want explode I'm actually
going through the list yeah just like
you know control F and like how are they
going to check IDs and everything like
you submit you scan it wow and so and
then there's the debate that a lot of
people will agree that PornHub and sites
like PornHub is subjectively bad because
they do not protect their creators
um it's dangerous it's just slipped up
one too many times so people say like
only fans is better only fans was not
created as a like adult content site it
was created as like patreon without any
kind of like content regulations they
are not a sex site and they're very very
clear about that so they do not have any
Protections in place for their creators
well I thought that would the way around
that was for their banking by saying
like hey we don't just focus on this we
allow anything and that's one of the
ways around how they can get like lines
of credit and a bank account and stuff
like that exactly but also they were
started initially it was during covid
that it blew up as like a sex site
because sex workers
like escorts didn't have jobs during
covet so they created only fans and
people think that it is safer because of
that or that it's like feminist porn
because women are producing it
themselves but it is often more
dangerous because there are no
regulations on the site because it is
not an adult site so only fans has no
way to report if like there's some guy
that's trying to pimp you out they do
not have many verification things
there's all of these studies mainly in
the UK of looking at kids who have
gotten on to only fans as creators or as
consumers because their age verification
you can submit an ID that is not yours
and still get an account so if you could
like wonder what this like story of a
girl who used her aunt's ID made it only
fans and it's 70 or 16 years old was
doing only fans content and then got
exploited like some crazy guy like found
her and like a bunch of stuff so they
just do not have those protections so
like if the industry itself is not even
safe like I understand like you have a
right to do whatever work you want to
make it Devil's Advocate yeah exactly
yeah but I don't think that one I don't
think it's healthy for society as a
whole I don't think that's doing
anything good for any of us but it's
like I get it if you know you want to
that's your problem let's say what about
what about prostitution because don't
they say that's the okay all right all
right let's go back again
is it the culture of porn itself or is
it porn in general
I think it's both so like I agree I
think culture around porn yes is
extremely toxic and it's very bad
probably an objective bat right yeah
let's take porn itself okay with two
very intentional no no two very
intentional people consenting into this
whatever transactional relationship yeah
how is that bad
um if they are doing that then I guess
that's fine like if you want to make
videos in your own haul I guess maybe
it's the selling of it
what is it exactly about the selling of
it because people sell their bodies in
other ways that's very true
um I guess I I think in my mind that
goes back to the industry like will
there ever be
a safe way to present that pornography
but if there was then it would probably
be okay in the mind of Brett Cooper I
think on a moral level I would still say
no but I think I think you value
intimacy and having something that's
like you feel is protected and is yours
and is sacred I do too I 100 I value
intimacy I value all that stuff too but
at the same time I'm very much the type
where I don't want to be telling people
that know what they're going into what
they should and shouldn't be doing and
that's where I think I think in a
perfect world where it was totally safe
maybe I can't give a solid answer
because I still do not believe that it
is a a good for society I think people
are on a whole negative it is a bad
forces I would probably agree with that
yeah just because the culture is becomes
all and I think it's for the viewers but
also
I would look at the people who even if
they are you know consenting individuals
I was to look at that and be like you
know as Brad Cooper I don't think you're
making the right decision yeah like if I
had control over your life I would say
do not do that it is not going to be
healthy for you in the long run like you
are literally blowing up your reputation
what's what's unhealthy about it because
you're from the actresses or actors
perspective
um I guess I keep going back to number
one the industry is like very dangerous
but also on an emotional level if you
are just selling them yes yeah like
mental mentally emotionally you are
selling like the most biologically
intimate thing that you can do and
you're putting like a price tag on like
after that what else do you have to give
it's like you are literally breaking
through every barrier like you have no
privacy like this is the most intimate
thing that you can do I like I will
never say that that is objectively
healthy it goes against bile biology yes
is what you're saying yeah okay like
this is the most objectively private
intimate thing that we are now like
commercializing and selling I will never
say that that could ever be healthy so
you would say biological truths are
axiomatically correct
morally yes what did you just say I'm
sorry okay that's something I would
actually kind of agree with to a certain
extent okay so just so everyone knows
yeah okay because I feel like people are
gonna it's gonna start thinking like oh
Jack he's like it's crazy porn guy
whatever okay because uh we've had two
porn stars on the show before okay and
people said that it looked like I fell
in love with the porn stars which is not
the case okay but that's like what the
what the viewers got basically out of
that I have a very intense stare yeah um
yeah I'm listening intently yeah yeah I
do but like I I um I agree porn culture
is extremely dangerous and I think porn
itself you're just taking two consenting
people I think that's probably fine I'm
not this crazy porn person in case of
you guys watching or wondering okay I
don't even watch porn I I will say
openly I used to watch porn and you know
this Graham I don't watch porn anymore
no and I've found my life incredibly
admirable thank you it's very very hard
to do it's also very very rare to find
men that will openly say that that you
used to watch porno that you quit porn
yeah both okay yeah that you like used
to and that you quit or the you like
actively don't it's very rare and I'm
somebody that like brings it up I'm like
so let's talk about that and it's like
so I feel neutral like I just don't care
either way I I think I think if two
people are consenting and they're not
hurting anybody I'm all for it right I
think there's a place for it I think
there's a Marketplace I think there's a
market for it but if we go back to yeah
on the side of the consumer some people
you get rid of the market if you get rid
of like the audience then but then it's
going to go underground then there's
going to be something else like making
it illegal or whatever but if like the
culture changes and we start to kind of
like you know in a similar way to how
like sobriety is very very cool now like
there's all of these like mocktail bars
that are opening up and that sort of
thing it's like if the culture starts
changing around it around it the market
starts changing I still think that's
such a small subset yeah like the
mocktail industry I think that's so cool
uh Macy was even she ordered a mocktail
for the five I had no idea those things
existed and I tried it it was actually
really cool like I like it but I see
these these changes but I think it's
such a small part of the market yeah
yeah five percent hope for that because
I still see it as like a productive
change I shall see those people as
people that are going going out and
having conversations in their community
and maybe changing minds or you know
opening people up to a new thing I think
that that's exciting but I do put a lot
of fault on the consumers because if
there was not such a porn culture and
consumption of porn there would not be a
market for it people would not go into
it thinking that it was some kind of
everything you said because isn't that
the oldest profession don't they call
that I think so yeah I would say I don't
I don't know but isn't it prostitution
but I know but isn't that similar on a
similar way but just because it's
existed for a long time to make it but I
feel like that that should also be legal
I mean if two okay consenting adults are
are wanted enter into a business
arrangement I actually I probably agree
prostitution should be legal yeah and
this you probably disagree with this but
I just think people you know give them
the right to do whatever they want for
the most part yeah I think again I
always go back to the industry around it
of like and maybe maybe the argument
that it's like that you know it's legal
and there's more you know protections
and all of that stuff maybe it could be
a different thing but I just because
something has been around for a long
time or has been done in my mind does
not make it yeah right or immorally
right so I look at that and I still
think that I don't think that people you
know should be doing I don't think that
that's the healthy thing to do would I
legislate that I don't know that's why I
would never be a politician because I
like to be able to have nuanced
conversations I think I'd be in a
terrible position but I I do believe
that it is unhealthy for people I
believe that you know selling your body
is unhealthy I believe that paying for
sex is unhealthy and so I wouldn't like
never Advocate yeah but technically in
the bigger picture when you consider the
entire timeline of humanity slavery has
only not existed for a very short period
of time this is because something is
crazy
still does exist in many countries yes
of course yeah so I will say this though
I just want to make sure we wrap this up
okay
if you guys want to quit porn I would
encourage it I saw my life improve and I
I want to openly say this because it's
an uncomfortable conversation because I
know my grandma watches this hopefully
she's not gonna be tuned
hello Gigi my dad sometimes watches
sorry Dad
um but yeah I don't watch porn and I've
saw my life extremely like drastically
improved and yeah the way that I saw
improve I don't want to go into too much
detail but mostly I think that I stopped
seeking like instant gratification with
certain things and I I started seeing
the world through a lens of like okay
I'm in this for the Long Haul I'm gonna
find someone I want to like settle down
you felt like that was holding you back
from finding somebody
it definitely made me so much less
motivated to try to find someone yes
absolutely yeah because you got that
instant gratification exactly and then
why would you need to have a real life
woman yeah okay we're good for the day
let's whatever whatever interval of time
it was okay I'm not disclosing too much
right here yeah we're good for the
minute no and that is the experience of
a lot of men and if you look at like the
studies yes about you know especially
men but it's interesting now because
there's so many more women that are you
know my argument on that is boredom when
you're bored you look for things to do
when you're working and oh that's the
most dangerous one is what I'm saying
but if someone is like on a mission and
they have stuff to do and they're busy
and they're working and they're doing
something productive that's not
something you think about it's it's like
when you're bored there's nothing to do
well boredom I will say contrarian
opinion right here I think boredom is
actually extremely productive and I
think during boredom when you're in
solitude and you're like not being like
allowing kids to be bored is I think one
of the like 100 yeah being exposed to
like technology and all that stuff I
think being bored is extremely powerful
it forces you to like create your own
fun yeah an introspect and like question
your beliefs which I think people just
don't do nowadays and I think that's
like one of the biggest problems
open-mindedness and questioning your own
beliefs absolutely
I don't know I hate boredom I I just
think a lot of this could be destroyed I
don't think it's like people love
boredom like I don't think it's
necessarily something to love but I
would say like it yields yeah
yeah I just think a lot of this can be
taken down to when when someone has
stuff to do they're less likely to
partake in things that are maybe not the
most productive for them I think it's a
symbiotic symbiotic relationship where
like both if you're obviously like if
you're occupied all the time you're
working all the time probably not going
to do this but at the same time if you
refrain from this it's probably going to
somehow translate back to more work
ethic and motivation and stuff like that
yeah yeah what questions do you have for
us oh my gosh
um I would say
I guess right off the bat for something
that's not political I'm just interested
in your hottest take I think I'm so like
in the middle of so many things I don't
really have any extremes on either end
that's wild honestly I I just like
people that as long as they don't hurt
anybody
thinker if you're an open thinker with
nuanced opinions you have to have some
sort of opinion because the masses are
not over oh yes open-minded things I'm
not a fan of rank control I think we
need to build more property oh yeah I
mean
that's crazy I hate rent control yeah
like I'm all for people doing what they
want to do like that that's it like
fiscally I'd say we could you know cut
back and we could yeah
the fact that that's like controversial
these days is wild to me it's like if
you don't if it takes like two
percentage of a brain to see like who we
are in a terrible terrible situation but
yeah all right let me think of some
other ones that are less
depression meds and anxiety meds are
over prescribed yeah that's awesome
I also think people have way more
control over their life than they think
so that's awesome I also think that ADHD
is over diagnosed
that's I mean that's and I think it's
screwed up an entire generation I was
diagnosed with ADD and I took uh
Adderall yeah for like two years
I also think hormonal birth control is
bad I don't think women should be on
birth control I don't know anything
about that it's terrible
um well it's chemical birth control so
you know doctors will tell you like
oh we can you know help your acne we can
do all this we'll regulate your Cycles
but they don't actually regulate
yourself as being on the pill all it
does is like chemically disrupt your
hormones and stop
like needed hormones for your body not
just for your reproductive cycle but for
your full like mental well-being as a
woman
it will be disrupted by that it's
artificial it is chemical long-term
effects like a lot of women have a lot
of you know problems getting pregnant
after being on birth control for a long
time it changes who you are attracted to
because your pheromones are different
um and your hormones are all screwed up
and we are naturally so attracted to
people based on our biology and when
that is like chemically altered that
takes a toll
um different kinds of birth control I
mean obviously we see the impact like
how does a pill cause you to like you
know gain so much weight change so much
about your body your periods just stop
like our periods are not supposed to
just stop like that shows a serious
imbalance if you are like an unmedicated
non-hormonal hormonal birth control
your Cycles are unregulated or you are
like not regular like that's a problem
that you go to like a hormone specialist
and you fix it because you want to be
like that is because they have the
biological hormonal control so like the
copper IUD is probably the most popular
one
um but that I recently learned because
I've you know have a lot of friends on
that
um the way that that works is that it
you know they usually say it just keeps
it from going and it you know gets the
sperm away that kind of thing it
actually makes the uterus an
inhospitable environment for any kind of
sperm and any kind of pregnancy it is a
inflammation of the uterus but that
inflammation is not localized so when
you have a copper IUD your entire body
is inflamed constantly because you have
a piece of metal in you and so it's full
inflammation which is why a lot of women
say that they have like you know they
struggle with mental health after you
know having that there's a reason why
your periods get super heavy I mean you
get awful PMS makes it really really bad
usually your iron gets depleted when you
have one because you are losing so much
blood more than you need to be
um and it does not stop fertilization
and that's the thing that like woke me
up is that you can still have a
fertilized egg and then you have like
what you know was often described to me
it was like kind of a spontaneous
abortion of like it just does not allow
the egg to stick
um and so that isn't great either
obviously I would probably say that
that's better than like a hormonal thing
that's like screwing with your hormones
but it's still like there really isn't a
great option but I do think that we do
not talk to young women enough about and
I say this as a young woman who did not
learn any of this about how to regulate
your cycle naturally because there are
things that you know you can eat there
are toxins that we are ingesting and
interacting with that screw with women's
hormones we should all be very regular
like that is how we are naturally
designed so that you can literally track
you know those 28 days and know exactly
when you're ovulating and you can only
get pregnant for three to five you know
it's really just three days in that
cycle
um and you know even if that's not like
a 99 but if you are religiously tracking
if you use other forms of protection
like it's very very secure but we don't
even teach girls that like they don't
even know where to start when I started
learning this I had no clue where to
turn because I was never even presented
as an option to me or something that was
so like scientifically modern like the
FDA is now approved like natural cycles
as an actual form of birth control now
it's the only actual non-hormonal
non-invasive form of protein and so I
would say
that I think hormonal birth control is
bad I don't think non-hormonal is much
better even though it's probably better
for a lot of people and I have friends
that have had great experiences with
copper IUD but I just think we need to
better equip women
because you literally have no idea how
your body works I had no idea about the
hormones that I go through every single
month I had no idea about any of my
cycle and the fact that it is so
scientific down to the day that you can
regulate it interesting yeah okay I want
to know what your most hot take is I
want to see if there's a thing we can
disagree on so we can have some sort of
like okay quasi debate
um I'm anti-death penalty
could go either way on that morally I do
think
there are some offenses that I would be
you know like child rape and that sort
of thing I'm like castrate the [__] out
of you like I do not care yeah but the
way that this system is set up
I wouldn't I'm anti because of that like
there are so many you know cases where
even if in one case they ruled it wrong
and we took a life like why do we have
like why are we allowed to play God why
as a jury or a judge a lot yeah I would
say life is the most precious thing oh I
saw a tick tock on that it was so sad
the kid uh was put to the death penalty
I think he was like 16 years old 17
years old and then they found out like
40 years later he was innocent oh that's
like a substantial yeah and and also one
thing that I think really struck me is
that
a lot of people say that it's cheaper
but it's not because you have to get so
much for years yeah and the litigation
too and the victim's family has to keep
coming back yeah like imagine you know
something awful happens to your child
your loved one whatever and you have to
keep going back year after year after
year testifying doing all of this it's
like at that point I just want to get on
with my life put them behind bars for
Life how about this how about assisted
suicide how do you feel on that I'm
anti-it anti yeah and I just ah
so I'm looking at what is happening in
Canada right now and it's happening to
the most vulnerable population so we
were talking about like the mentally ill
on the street they're you know going up
to these people and that's kind of
that's their solution right now is that
oh if you're so mentally if you're if
you are so unhappy here's this you know
State assisted suicide it's like that's
your best option but you go for that
what if someone is terminally ill I
think that's a totally different
conversation it is okay I think it's
just the legality of assisted suicide
not necessarily the culture of it yeah
the legality of it in general like do
you support the theory of it
um I think if somebody was terminally
terminally ill
I think that would be the only time that
I would be morally for it or and like
think that it was like legally you know
maybe okay I think that would be very
hard as like the family member that was
watching that or being involved I don't
think I don't know how I would react to
that but I also know people who are you
know there's no other way and they want
to go you know at their own especially
like older people who it's like I don't
want to suffer anymore I can understand
that argument but what really bothers me
is that like people are tatting this
around it's like oh we're you know we're
helping all these people you know all
these homeless people you know they
don't really have like a point to live
and it's like that that's your option
you know we're talking about like what
do we do for this you know vulnerable
population how do we clean up our
streets how do we make it safer and it's
like this is what Canada is trying to do
and it's you know and I'm looking I see
the videos of people who you know have
been offered assisted suicide and it's
like some of them were talking and you
know they were saying like if this had
been offered to me like a year prior I
would have taken it and then over the
last year like my life has gotten so
much better I finally you know took the
leap and I you know made all these
changes it's like that's terrifying to
me
but again it's less of like somebody
else playing God but it's like we're
offering that to people as this like
right all right yes I don't think that
that's like a copy mentally ill people
as well yeah yeah and it's like that
feels like taking advantage of them and
if that's the best you can do then I
have a real problem with that keep
trying yeah come up with some no I mean
because
yeah what is the goal of going into
Political commentary is it to strengthen
the base of the conservative population
or is to share your opinion and hope to
be heard and understood by the other
side of the Liberals and maybe change
their opinion
I think it can be both I don't think it
needs to be either or I was talking
about this actually on a live stream
yesterday
um I think a lot of conservatives get
themselves caught up in trying to change
people's minds when I think back to you
know me feeling very alienated as you
know college student sharing my opinions
you know losing friends that sort of
thing somebody speaking directly to me
and saying your opinions are not crazy
there are people that you know think
like you and being empowered and being
told it is okay to speak up and you know
having somebody that is unwavering in
their values and I think Matt Walsh is
somebody who is incredible at that
because he does not Bend at all he is
not somebody that's like I'm not gonna
like find he like says it I'm not gonna
find common ground with you because most
of the stuff that he talks about is in
regards to like his children's lives and
like that kind of thing he will not
waver and I think he is incredibly
empowering especially at his audience of
parents of like getting them to speak up
and say it is okay to defend your
children in this way it is okay to have
this opinion there are others like you
and I think if we forget the base and if
we are consistently just trying to like
spend all of our time going out and
reaching everybody else and it's like
what happens to everybody you know here
so I think you kind of have to you know
I think it's important on both sides I I
would I like to try to do both
in my content
um I think that the manner in which I
speak and the topics that I speak about
make it more palatable for people who
disagree with me and I like that I like
the fact that I look at my comments and
I see people disagreeing but in a
healthy way it's like the most inspiring
thing to me and people having like
healthy conversations in a YouTube
comment section is absurd and I'm like
that's actually very very cool
um and I like the fact that I see
comments where somebody says you know
I'm like more Center left and I actually
relate to you on some things and I've
learned a lot even though I disagree
with you on things I you know I find
your content enjoyable it's like that's
a huge win for me but I also look at
comments and at the same level seeing
like a 16 year old kid who's like I you
know live in Los Angeles everybody
thinks differently than me I feel so
alone and I hear your content and I feel
empowered not to feel scared to talk
about my beliefs that's a huge win
because I was that kid and I felt like I
was totally alone and like everybody
around me was crazy and I literally I
did not know who to look up to and if I
can be that for somebody else then
that's also win for me
see the problem that I see with some of
the leaders of the conservative and the
liberal movements is the fact that they
are so aggressive to the other side and
it's like constantly shooting down the
other side and I feel like if you
actually really wanted to make some
grounds it's and hopefully transfer some
people or open up the other side's
perspective uh you wouldn't be so
aggressive but come from more of a place
of like compassion and understanding and
that's the one thing that I just I can't
seem to get over as a viewer because I
watch Ben Shapiro and I also watch
Destiny and I watch us on and I watch
you and I see all of this stuff I
literally watch from both sides but
that's the one pill I just simply cannot
swallow that frustrates the heck out of
me when I'm watching content like this
it's like if you really care about the
end goal of achieving what you want to
achieve and hopefully like if you really
believe your ideology is better than the
other one and you want this ideology to
take power yeah wouldn't the most
effective and efficient way to get there
to be hopefully transferring some of the
people on the other ideology side over
to your side therefore people people
respond very poorly to critics like
negative criticism right at least in a
negative light right but they respond
very very well to compassion
understanding yeah and I feel like if
the sides could just have a little bit
more compassion understanding to the
other side I think probably a big part
of it though is imagine someone else
comes at you and you're like okay well
maybe uh you know they had some points
you do that and then everyone questions
well what about everything else that you
said yeah maybe you're going to change
those beliefs too it's like if you do
that you lose that exactly so I think
you need to be consistent so I think the
important thing to do is that I don't
bend my values to appease anybody else I
don't change my opinions to appease
anybody else but I am very open with my
audience like I you know I've talked
about Dylan Mulvaney a lot who's the you
know the transgender
um person who like you know blew up on
Tick Tock now has like 10 million is
like a transgender influencer talked
about them a lot
um very very controversial and there's a
lot of things they've said that I do not
agree with especially in regards to
children
but I am always very open about the fact
that I like their personality and I used
to subscribe to Dylan's Channel and you
know Dylan's Tick Tock before you know
he became she Dylan
um because I thought his content was
hysterical and super funny and he was
like a great like this cute little gay
guy and all of this stuff and I and very
few people on my side of it are willing
to acknowledge that but I've like I
watched Dylan's stuff for ages like all
throughout covid and I'm willing to say
I still have that like fondness and I
want to be compassionate for what Dylan
is going through and that sort of thing
but I won't Bend or change how I feel
about the subject and about the ideas
that they are sharing but I will find a
way to have some kind of human
connection with the story that I'm
talking about same way as if I'm like
dealing with a celebrity
you know I will say like I still like
the music whatever like I will
acknowledge the fact that I'm not so
black and white that if I hate like a
singer's you know ideology or things
that they will say no I still really
like your songs like that's cool
um I am also unafraid to criticize my
own side if we're being idiots about
something now I think a big part of that
is just criticizing people for absurd
stuff like Emma Watson when she had that
really unflattering photo of her taken
back in the summer people like this is
what wokism does to you it's like no
she's a 30 year old woman who has not
gotten any work done which I thought
that we were promoting that we didn't
want women to be like fake and whatever
she's natural she got caught in a bad
light and you're now slander over I've
never seen the picture it was like her
like forehead was all like it was like
huge on right wing Twitter really and
they were like this is what like wokism
does to you and they would like put a
photo for her from like 10 years ago
when the photo here it was like that why
are you spending your time debating that
like you're attacking somebody who has
done nothing right now obviously we
could have a conversation about Emma
Watson's you know like hatred of JK
Rowling about her policies we are going
after a woman's looks to have a quick
dunk on Twitter and feel good about
yourself and I think being able to
criticize your own side when they are
genuinely being stupid I think that that
humanizes you as well so you don't feel
so polarized and I think the best people
that I follow and the best mentors I
have are willing to do that and are
willing to say you know what this was
actually a win on the left they did a
good job or something you know on the
right of like you we royally effed up
and this is not productive whatsoever
yeah because if you are so caught in
just winning winning winning winning
winning constantly at the expense of
everything especially winning a quick
like click or immediate hit or that kind
of thing it's like what's the point
that's the thing like I remember Ben
Shapiro honestly he kind of went viral
and he built his entire career based off
of like Ben Shapiro destroys like yeah
facts and logic or something like that
and it's just like some kid walking up
to the podium yeah oh gosh you know it
just completely my favorite one was the
one kid said like uh well how do you
know boy scouts or boys
like it's like those moments yeah yeah
um but but the only thing is it's like
okay obviously for profit like that
makes sense as a business you got to get
the clicks and everything but I just
wish I'm like look he could say
something like look I understanding
you're coming from a place of heart and
it's probably not and you know something
like this and like feeling like he has
compassion for the other person yeah
because then he wouldn't have well he
probably still still would maybe not I
don't know have these like hordes of
people all showing up and like
protesting him when he goes to speak at
these colleges because they want to hear
what he has to say they want to hear
this quick comebacks that's what they
come that's what they think I know but I
feel like it's like 80 20. like you
still get like 80 of the value when you
still like as you listen destroy them
but like hear those like moments or miss
things but if you like listen to like
Ben's full like four hour for the show
yeah totally different so I think it is
like you know in those like quick debate
things like that's the format of them
and they're supposed to be very very
fast but when you hear him do his like
his Sunday special that he does is one
of my favorite things because he usually
brings people that he disagrees with and
it's like a four hour conversation and
it's the most like respectful like he he
truly is compassionate and he's like the
most digestible relatable person
um and I think in that form but it's
hard in yeah have you thought about
doing that with like bring yeah bring
something online yeah we're working like
disagree I would love to see that
because I think that you know those
conversations are not had very often but
also they're very difficult for short
form stuff they like really lend
themselves to the long form yeah you
have to spend you know over three hours
with people really diving into it and
that's what you know Ben Sunday
specialist is hours and hours and what
Jordan Peterson does hours and hours of
speaking to people but most people don't
want to sit there and watch all of that
so they only see the clips and those
viral moments obviously yeah bring Fame
and that sort of thing but they're viral
for a moment or for a reason right I
just do think that there could be a
shift in general for like daily wire
other like liberal media companies uh to
have a little bit more compassion for
the Assad I think that there's a huge
contingent of people right in the middle
still I know it's hard to believe
especially with like how aggressive
everybody is on each side and uh the
gravitational pull from each side but I
think there's still a lot of people in
the middle and that could really be
claimed by either side if you just came
with a little bit more compassion and
care for the other side I forget how
many people were in the middle but it's
it's like 90 percent of people are in
the middle but the 10 on either side
they're the ones who really show up to
vote yeah yeah and so you get like those
people really getting together yeah
exactly no I agree with you and that's
something that I do try to do and I
think that that's something that shows
through in my content and I think that
that's why most of my audience is
younger because gen Z wants that gen Z
values like emotional connection and
that sort of thing more and there's a
reason why I do make a very very
concerted effort to be human when I'm
dealing with these stories and if
they're all like very personal to me
especially when I'm doing dealing with
like gender ideology and that sort of
thing like if I get like emotional with
those stories it's because like these
are all people I grew up with like a
majority of my friends from you know
high school and that sort of thing have
either transitioned or are you know gay
have literally chopped off their boobs
and that kind of thing like these are
literally friends that I you know know
and so I'm never gonna like scream in
their faces and that sort of thing and
say you're not real but it's like I will
speak out about you know my opinions I
won't shy away from that but I will
always acknowledge that it's like this
is still a person
and you know if you are going after
children that's a different thing and I
will not pull any punches and I do not
give a [__] at all but if you are an
adult I will still have you know
compassion for you you're still a human
being
um and I think it's just you know
Different Strokes for different folks
about how you know the tone that they
use but I do think that's one of the
reasons why my content is effective
especially with this generation so with
that said I don't know when the audio
cut out guys this has been a super long
episode and we've done something outside
of the norm we want to leave our comfort
zones and have on people with very
challenging opinions so with that said
you guys if you enjoy content like this
please leave a comment down below
because we are very excited for our
guest coming on next Sunday yeah
surprise you guys there's gonna be some
drama okay and uh yeah let us know if
you want more content like this Graham
you want to do your thing yeah as usual
make sure to subscribe Instagram jlt
time
dude wait wait actually what's your name
Carter that's a great name Carter has
been what I've wanted to name my son for
the last like 10 years I've told
everybody since I was like a left no I
guess it was maybe 14 I was probably 12
when I made that decision that I was
gonna name my son Carter
you have a fantastic name my friend
thank you Carter thank you you're a
great guy everyone shout out Carter W
Carter okay down in the comments he did
everything so thank you thanks